there's no time
13 o clock
[Music]
hey folks its episode 171 our
Thanksgiving special yeah Thanksgiving
around the corner it is yeah this is
gonna go up a couple of days before
Thanksgiving if you're in the United
States it's ridiculous what's the show
gonna be about yeah well I'm doing kind
of like a sort of like I did well in the
Halloween one where it's just kind of
like a variety show I just want to talk
about like real history Thanksgiving and
then kind of get into like a kind of the
darker side of colonial history want to
talk about a Pequot War I want to talk
about the first murderer in colonial
America Thanksgiving
sort of yeah you know oh and I also want
to talk about some Reese what's not that
reason but it's kind of a recent thing
where they discovered that there may
have been cannibalism in Jamestown the
first okay yeah erican settlement so
they had suspected it but they found
like physical evidence of it they were
getting hungry so yeah it's pretty nasty
but yeah so this is kind of just gonna
be like a Thanksgiving and Thanksgiving
adjacent type of show will probably end
up talking about food too because we
usually do that it's [ __ ] ridiculous
we're trying to diet right before
Thanksgiving first it was big I've been
bulking you know done a bulking plan
diet I'm getting so big I'm getting
stretch marks in my fall my [ __ ] I
know he's like pregnant but in his arms
getting stretch marks I'm just swelling
up like that and what was funny is it
started when I started working out less
yeah more recovery time more time to
grow yes
yeah I was going for like three well
lifting three times a week to about two
times a week sometimes one time a week
and it just bizarre but I you know I was
working I was doing it for a year so I
guess I'd been sending the right signals
to do it to go locust yeah that's when a
[ __ ] goes locust you go from
grasshopper to locust we're just talking
about
give it time to grow yeah but yes I was
on all that bulking eating and eating
and eating jenny was equid we got fat as
[ __ ]
well that's what I mean it's like that's
right I will see the thing about it is
that and it runs in my family too I
unfortunately I didn't get like my dad's
side of the family like all the way we
were like pretty skinny and like they
just ate meat and just didn't get gained
any weight unfortunately I got my mom's
side of the family I got their
metabolism really the only way I can
lose any weight is by like sticking to a
thousand calories a day less than you're
supposed to have but I just I can't eat
any more than that otherwise I will just
be 300 pounds sorry I respond quickly I
respond quickly to you know lifting and
working out as I think you have to be
that way in order to survive the army -
I think I think you just kind of
selected going through all that hardcore
infantry basic training and stuff people
who don't recover quickly just make it
weaker yeah so they don't make it do
basic I think a lot of it but yeah but
I'll gain I'll gain fat - but I lose it
fast also well yeah well you're a guy
yeah it's like for some reason women in
general like their bodies just they're
like no we need the fat just a bit so
you know yes I'm gonna go into cutting
phase that's what we've been trying to
cut like I said we're still gonna do
Thanksgiving and we're gonna do like
yeah I mean it works do that that well
yeah I'm gonna work out though that's
just like one day and we could like you
know exercise extra yeah you know I mean
cuz it's only gonna be two of us and we
got like cuz man we went to winn-dixie
if you live in the south you know it's
like when dick sees big grocery store
chain I know they don't have those in
other parts of the country but uh they
had turkeys on sale what were they 49
cents a pound
yeah we got two tours I got 40 pounds of
Turkey it's what you have on certain
sweet info yeah I got it for 20 bucks
hey good pass on it's so cheating well
they only let you buy two you at once go
back there and get some more well we can
go back and get another one
well I mean I love Turkey was we did the
same thing last year cuz they were so
cheap it's like we bought two or three
of them and then we had one for thanks
and then we had one for Christmas - I
think our and then we had one like later
in the year yeah I got that big a spot I
got the guys you're talking about deeper
in it yeah I got that [ __ ] charcoal
grill and I can put it down it oh man
deep fry I'll make at reduct and put a
turkey on side of a duck turkey the
people in other parts of the world have
turducken what is that is that just an
American thing that's a [ __ ] white
trash thing that seems like a very
American
yeah and shouldn't stuff in a turkey
with more birds yeah like with a it's
like a deep fry knit [ __ ] yeah it's like
it's like a fowl or a Boros or yeah it's
just kind of leave me people out if you
guys have never heard of it I don't know
maybe there's somewhere in Europe or in
Mongolia and weird places like that
where they don't deep-fried Turkey deep
frying a turkey is [ __ ] outstanding
cuz it can't it doesn't lose as much
moisture
yeah it's sealed in I feel like it kind
of got to be like that got to be like a
really big thing like the last maybe 10
20 years yeah it's a big dress that the
skin gets crisp and it seals it all in
there it's fantastic I mean I like a
yeah I don't think you could do it with
with it with Thanksgiving stuffing in
there maybe somebody's figured out a way
I don't know I think the oil might
penetrate the stuffing although maybe
not because you can deep-fry a hushpuppy
so you can deep-fry its it might just be
like you have a nice Cheerios out there
I don't know I don't look it up I just
you know there's some kind of recipe for
that somewhere I don't know maybe we
could do that later I think I'd rather
have arrested one for yeah Thanksgiving
that's just the turkey day so we're
talking about Turkey well yeah that's
what I mean you know we're talking about
like kind of food issue it's a white
meat it's very lean it's high in protein
and low in carbs low in calorie it's a
perfect meat go down there and just eat
chicken breasts and wings and turkey
lengths not wings with legs
what turkey wigs aren't that good all
right honestly I'm I'm I'm a dark meat
yeah I mean I like the white meat - oh
I'll eat turkey was like whatever way
but I like chicken - I like thighs the
cornbread stuffing yeah we're kind of
like I said I think it's just gonna be
two of the two of us right and the
kiddies will eat off that [ __ ] for
[ __ ] weeks yeah but yeah we gotta we
still got enough pumpkin left to make
like I make a cup of pumpkin pies we're
gonna make like cornbread stuffing real
mashed potatoes yeah I'll make some real
mashed potatoes and whip them cuz I mean
you know we don't go all out like that
no I'm not gonna be the cream style corn
not gonna do the creamed corn they're
saying it's good but it just seems like
yeah it's to market to miss very much I
might I might I might you know I might
go down there and get you know you hate
it but make that cream green bean
casserole yes yeah you know I gotta let
you do kind of have to make one cuz it's
like traditional I guess yeah you gotta
use canned stuff yeah traditional from
the 50s yeah I think it was invented by
Campbell's Soup yeah in like 1955 yeah
Unni you ain't use up any like cream of
mushroom soup or whatever the [ __ ] you
put in it any you alien beings from
foreign cultures and [ __ ] yeah don't
have Mars or don't have a high culture
like like we do here anything that say I
don't understand the beauty of
Campbell's cream of mushroom soup out of
the can pour it into a bunch of canned
green beans with some with some of those
can't what do you call it crunchy fake
onion rings on the top of it yeah like
this French's Rick's friend are you yeah
[ __ ] white trash that's the easy go
down in that yeah you can't beat it
he's messing with the camera yeah you
see War of the Worlds leave the tripod
alone she's mad because we brought her
in asking me to take her bag outside but
I don't like her running around outside
while work yeah yeah I might have to go
do that
yeah just let's bite you I'm not I don't
just I don't feel spite it is that yeah
that's like something you would tell me
not to do no don't do that
well you can do it if you want just keep
in mind that you're gonna be the one
eating the other thing oh yeah oh I know
you will
yeah like I said I'm very we're gonna
win Dixie and get that [ __ ] as far as
like eglee Wiggly just a thing we don't
have a pig
we anymore just think we had one in
Daytona when I was growing up but I wish
I could buy it from Piggly Wiggly that
would make it even more solid
who the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] idea was it
to come back or do it back in the 50s
it's dead now but didn't want him Piggly
Wiggly we call them pigs you know Jim
pigs it wiggle I'll give him that they
do Wiggles little piglets I don't know I
don't even know Phil in business yeah
Mississippi I saw one oh you did just
recently that was lucky but I think it's
like a minor grocery store now yeah kind
of like maybe it's like Goodings it
didn't become like a light or like roses
yeah never roses department stores
probably gone now yeah I'm gonna have to
look that up now I'm like really curious
anybody knows out there if you have a
Piggly Wiggly buddy like let me know
yeah cuz you know we're gonna win Dixie
they were right alongside winn-dixie in
Mississippi we like it's pretty much
just here it's winn-dixie it's
Publix and you know like Whole Foods and
[ __ ] like that we used to have Food Lion
but I think that might have gone out of
business or as going out of business
because there was one of those cuz where
I you know where I've used to live in
Daytona a few years ago we had like a
winn-dixie and then like right across
the street there was a Food Lion you
gave me excited about this Thanksgiving
I'm excited about thinking about
especially because we've been like kind
of starving ourselves last couple days
yeah I'm gonna make I'm gonna make real
cranberry sauce I make it out a whole
cranberries yeah and then I'm gonna make
make mine don't make two gravies yeah
yeah yeah I'm gonna make you regret
gravies
when I was gonna have giblets in it the
other one's gonna be the stuff I the
stockpot yeah the onions and the celery
out the stockpot in inside the the the
stock that all that all the turkey necks
and the gizzard and the [ __ ] heart
was all cooked in yeah I'll just take
the meat out of there just blend it with
that tree and I'll be good and the onion
in there cuz I'll have a whole onion in
there and then the celery in there and
it'll blend into like a green gravy it
all gravy fire
[Laughter]
and then all the meat I'm gonna put that
in the UH turkey gravy yeah I don't
think I'm gonna use the liver though now
that liver gets like liver I don't mind
the giblets but the liver gets - yeah
it's - cuz I think did you did you put
the ad Edward Internet like last year
the year before and here was like we
could really taste it yeah I put I put
the whole liver in there a price should
have put like maybe one third of that
lip yeah like just to have a slight
flavor of it but it was strong although
some people really liked that some
people who are in yeah liver is a very
acquired because it's a very very strong
flavor yeah those weird limeys and red
coats and [ __ ] they eat all that yeah
they would love that [ __ ] cuz they like
those stuff that comes out with the
animals you like the stuff that we throw
away they like budget they throw that
[ __ ] away in Mississippi than English
you eat it make a sausage Adam well hey
it's like you know the gut
don't waste it that's an internal organ
I like I am [ __ ] with these people I
like him I like some of it you eat
chicken hearts come love chicken hearts
I eat a thousand chicken Hartigan hearts
yeah a whole balls up cuz you kinda cute
that's in Brazil yeah there's a big
thing in Brazil Brazil they have a they
have a barbecue thing called show house
Korea an issue house coat in a South
Korea they'll have a guys dressed as
Gauchos run around damp swords with meat
on the swords boys vegetarians and
vegans like Oh Sophie she'd get pissed
it's just thrusting yeah it's just all
me it's just all me and they got the
sword with cooked meat on there and like
one guy's running around with nothing
but just lines and lines and dozens of
damn chicken hearts on on a sword and
I'll like yeah bring them on there
salted and you bring them on and there
look at me like I'm crazy like how you
gonna eat all the real good [ __ ] because
then considered that the good [ __ ] yeah
the good [ __ ] is you know he of course
it on the beef and hump of the Brahma
bull I got that in there all kinds of
cool [ __ ] man put awesome [ __ ] pork
awesome [ __ ] pork yeah I mean
Brazilian meat was better than American
meat by far
leave from at least when I was there
yeah it was fantastic
I feel like something needs to be named
sword full of chicken hearts I had some
that Argentine beef too from the Papa's
and all that another disease that was
better huh yeah and you know that was a
world-renowned meat yeah everybody yeah
but they feed him corn
yeah well yeah they're grass-fed in
Brazil too I believe they were they just
came off of farms you know the Cowboys
had chased him around and big hurt it's
kind of like they did here a long time
ago yeah well they do that still in
certain places yeah yeah it's just you
know it's good yeah we are looking
forward to Thanksgiving
looking forward a skip I think we're
just okay so let's go ahead and do these
shoutouts before we get fat well
hopefully with if we got fat just from
talking he's talking about you then we'd
really be in trouble talking about that
was a seven thousand calorie just got
hahaha I may take a little bit more
about it later because I wanted to talk
about like what they actually ate like
the quote-unquote first Thanksgiving but
I thought I wasn't any good I kind of
want to get into that a little bit
because what people think of is the
first Thanksgiving there's a lot of like
I didn't hear about that I think I heard
that they did have those pies pumpkin
pie I don't think that they did not at
the first one I don't think they had any
dessert II stuff okay they did have
pumpkins and squash and things like that
but I think they had them like in a
difference my understand that that was a
pumpkin was available they did yeah
they did the Indians were the Indians on
the East Coast they were deep into that
yeah they're on that yeah they grew
pumpkins and squash and evidently enough
pecans and things like pecan pie and
pecan stuffed inside of animals like
birds you know talking about yeah like a
stuffing that was made out of you know
things like fruit and nuts together
which they do that in England back in
those days they did like weird minced
meats type stuff they did that for a
long time they were making that here but
go ahead and I think some people still
do that here like with the stuffing or
dressing if you want to call it that
some people call it stuffing when it's
in the bird and dressage as you might
get separate yeah but some people put
like cranberries and [ __ ] like that in
there that's not that weird I mean you
know yeah all right so no cranberries we
were wearing those colonies are around
there they they're from that area
later they during that time yeah they
might have put it some other [ __ ] in the
road that's like fruit or nuts or
something late 1400s yeah but uh alright
so we just had a couple of shout outs
that I wanted to do um obviously I think
I mentioned this pretty much every week
but faceless villain three and my
fiction horror fiction book associated
villanies is out in audio format so if
you want to check that out you can like
I said I'm still working on the audio
for my other fiction compilation hopeful
monsters I got a bunch of the stories
Brad I haven't started I haven't edited
them yet but I gotta just you know keep
doing that also I mentioned this last
time but I'm thinking about in a few
months probably in probably and then
started in a year I'm gonna do like a
new little show where it's just like me
reading scary stories you know what I
mean this is like public domain stories
or like you know creepy stories from
reddit or whatever or some of my own
fiction or whatever and I'm just gonna
have they're each gonna be like about an
hour long and you know it'll just be
several like three or four stories like
in one thing and it'll just have like
creepy little visuals and stuff like
that because I know sometimes like
people just like to listen to like
creepy stories and people reading them
so I'm gonna do I have two episodes done
and I'm just gonna like stock some up
and then I might start putting them up
like in the new year maybe like maybe
once a week or once every couple weeks
show the [ __ ] like that also um big
shout out to Tiffany who sent us a
PayPal donation this week no I didn't
know about that so thank you very much I
probably told you but you probably
forgot yeah alright so let's talk about
the real history of Thanksgiving because
I feel like and I don't know I remember
when I was a kid in the 70s and early
80s they were still kind of teaching uh
you know the sort of mythical first
Thanksgiving story about the pilgrims
and they had kind of a shitty day and
then like the you know the Native
Americans like help them and like they
all kind of got together like for a big
party and it was like all like sunshine
and rainbows and show like that which
isn't exactly how [ __ ] happened
yeah let me say somebody yeah most of
American history was taught to kids
especially our our age had been they've
been taught for a long time yeah in that
way there's a lot of stuff that was
mythical like George Washington cutting
down cherry tree
yeah just put things like Paul Bunyan
would be man with the hand and that's a
fictional and that's a fictional said
because he's a giant rightly so he's not
real all that stuff was all that stuff
that's all it was a real common thing to
do in a civilization yeah what oh my
goodness oh I got other things I gotta
do oh that's a real common thing to do
for a civilization to give kind of like
mythical histories that went back to
Rome and that's because it was easy to
teach kids values and to teach them to
be you know supportive of their country
and at least have a basic idea of how
the country started and what it was all
about it was like a religion it was a
pseudo religion yeah it's like a
national religion and America does have
a national religion it still kind of
does oh yeah doesn't mean that it's
false in essence but it's it's a bunch
of memes yeah basically I know what I
always found interesting about it is
that even that if even if it's not true
it's kind of true it's cut well not only
that but it's also it says a lot about
like the national character yeah like
that like why these particular types of
stories hold like over maybe what really
happened now let me really blow some of
these people's minds I don't know if
you've been the show for a long time but
you know my connection with dr. Robert
and price Jesus myth you know Jesus
scholar and and and Jesus myth assists
actually the religions are like this too
yeah all of them not just nations a lot
of those religions are founded in memes
that didn't really happen
yeah but they meant something for the
character the religion the people that
wanted they were founded those religions
and wanted to continue them just because
it's in those religious books doesn't
mean it actually happened well animals
almost in no case yeah yeah like well
one thing I always found interesting
about
American history is that a lot of our
kind of memes like you said are our
legends and stuff like that are more
like tall tales they're not quite
they're not quite as fantastical as
maybe some of the ones from other parts
of the world they do tend to be like
more realistic but just exaggerated like
you said like look at Paul Bunyan yeah
who was like a lumberjack
but he was just he was a giant yeah but
he was like based on a real person but
it was just like exaggerated yeah and
the same thing like you you know our
National MS kind of like John Henry and
you know [ __ ] like their Pecos Bill and
stuff like that all that stuff was to
kind of kind of exemplify and kind of
teach young people and kids about the
expansion westward yeah Western
civilization in the form of the United
States really at that era the United
States it was just Western civilization
it was very much kind of like a I guess
you could say a mutant version of
England yeah but there was in certain
areas it was also Spain in France yeah
because there was the Louisiana Purchase
so just but the people telling the
stories are basically English people
separated by a couple generations yeah
but the thing about like the kind of
myth around Thanksgiving is kind of like
and maybe a lot of people know this now
and like I said I'm not really sure how
they teach it to like particularly
elementary school kids nowadays but
because it's like I remember you know
learning about you know the Pilgrims and
Squanto and you know him teaching them
and like suddenly everyone's like
getting along and then they had the
first Thanksgiving and it was like super
awesome and then they just like kind of
had it every year after that like you
know as a celebration of their alliance
I guess but that's really not at all how
it happened you know what I mean so it's
it's just interesting how that gets
taught and like I said if you if anybody
out there has like kids that are that
age like elementary school-age and
they're learning about Thanksgiving or
whatever it's like I'm kind of curious
as to like if they teach something like
a version that's like closer to the
truth now or if they still do the thing
like I was remember there's that um it's
not as popular or famous as the
Christmas one but the Charlie Brown like
the peanuts
they did a Thanksgiving one too and it's
like I feel like I can't remember
exactly what happened in it cuz like I
said they don't show it as much as the
Christmas one
but when didn't they try to like make a
Thanksgiving I think peppermint patty
like tried to make a Thanksgiving dinner
and she [ __ ] it up like she burned it
or something like that and then Snoopy
and Woodstock had to like save the day
and then they for Thanksgiving the
holiday ended up having like toast and
jelly beans and yeah it's popcorn I
think it was or something like because
they've messed up there's also kind of a
modern misconception or they would kind
of miscast what Thanksgiving was also
that it was just basically they try to
kind of soil it by saying well this is
just white people giving thanks for
giving to a new world no actually the
meaning was is they were giving it was
Indians and white people giving thanks
that they were in a new world living in
peace because that's part of that very
short time ago yeah well okay
that's another thing too in general
alliances between groups of whites and
groups of Indians lasted a long time
yeah but usually what happened was as a
couple generations would pass and the
agreements that they were made by
ancestors no longer applied yeah or you
had a lot of situations where whites and
their Indian allies would go to war
against other whites or other Indians
yeah it's it's not simple well like I
said it was never and we kind of talked
about this on some of our other shows
where it's like wherever you talk about
American history and they're always
talking about like you know that the
colonists and the Native Americans it's
like you can't really just say Oh Native
Americans because like a lot of those
tribes were like at war with each other
nation yeah and some of them allied with
the the colonists like against another
tribe because they've been fighting them
for a long time and it's like no they
tried to like have all these strategic
kind of thing so it's always kind of
like way more complicated than yeah it's
the Hollywood always wants to present
the Native American nations as some kind
of like hapten hapless victims no these
were able-bodied players and warriors
they were every bit as warlike as as
European nations they went to war with
each other just like European nations
were toward each other
yeah they had a lot of divisions between
them and they weren't all the same
ethnic group that's another thing well
yeah this was like this was a lot of
different this was a long time ago and
all those Indians some of those Indians
they were cousins do each other's but
some of them weren't really directly
related to each other yeah
you know cuz the immigration from both
Asia and Europe had happened Oh in
successive waves over tens of thousands
of years they had different racial
makeups yeah yeah so like I said it's
it's always like a lot more complicated
than anything so like I said you know
anything you know that kind of
simplifies the Thanksgiving story you're
saying like oh it was like this big
thing that's signified but that's cool
it's like you know it's nice to like
signify you know harmony between groups
that were fighting and like you know
give thanks for what you have and stuff
like that but you know it's always like
a lot more complicated and it sounds and
which makes it more interesting
yeah and the Thanksgiving story was true
in its essence in a way like parts of
energy because the colonists the
descendants of the colonists were the
new English the descendants of those
Indians were you know kind of like the
Mohicans in the North West Indian you
know to be the the North East Indian
nations and they interbred a lot they
were at peace mostly yeah a lot of the
other warfare stuff that was happening
was actually happening out in what they
called you know what would now be Texas
and yeah you know they did some have
some stuff going on in the south but it
wasn't really as violent in the
Northeast yeah maybe was because it was
cold yeah everyone was like [ __ ] we're
not going outside to do this [ __ ] well
the winner it was they were agricultural
based societies you needed a lot of
stability and competition or everyone
would die
yeah there's you me yeah it's you had to
have stability and and not constant
cooperation or you couldn't conduct
agricultural agriculture and they died
yeah I mean we went back to the I think
we talked about it for in the Salem
witch trials yeah at the during the time
of the witch trials most of the people
in Salem were Native American yeah even
though they had English names or at
least part Native American yeah like I
said there was a lot of interbreeding
yeah
the population there weren't enough
women well yeah so you know most guys
American Indian women and we'll kind of
get into that because we was gonna talk
a little bit about the Mayflower and
stuff like that like they first came
over instance so but what we know of as
Thanksgiving like the national holiday
it wasn't even proclaimed a national
holiday until 1836 you know Abe Lincoln
did that and then that was like in the
middle of civil war now interestingly
and I didn't know this but there's this
woman named Sarah Josepha Hale she was a
magazine editor and a writer and
apparently she had got a bee in her
bonnet about making Thanksgiving like a
national holiday on a specific day
because it had been celebrated like
sporadically but it wasn't like official
official so she really really wanted
that to happen because she thought you
know it would unify the country and it's
like you know it has like kind of a
religious significance at least it
started out I think a lot of people
don't really see it like that I like
Christmas yeah Christmas wasn't really
wasn't really uh didn't really celebrate
that so the 1800s yeah thanks to the
coca-cola company yeah they kind of had
a big have had a big part of the imagery
of it imagery a secular imagery sure the
secular imagery in like packaging and
the marketing of of of Christmas as we
know it was a very much a thing of the
coca-cola company yeah Santa Claus and
when he looked and just I think the
government was behind it though too
I think I think they wanted that holiday
yeah you know I had to go look back into
it I know the imagery is from coca-cola
a lot of it is yeah and then late
18-hundreds yeah and like I said even
before that you you had like you know
Puritans and stuff like that like back
and they said they didn't celebrate
Christmas because they thought it was
blasphemous or yeah thing like that
somehow but yeah so there had been so
this woman Sarah Josepha Hale who acts
incidentally she also wrote mary had a
little lamb so you know yeah she had
been on like a 36 year campaign to get
Thanksgiving designated as a national
holiday I mean she did like she wrote
letters and editorials and she just like
all the time they call her the mother of
Thanksgiving actually so finally she
just you know worked tirelessly for 36
[ __ ] years on this on this thing so
obviously very important to her
and you know finally in 1836 Abe Lincoln
declared it the national holiday 1836
1836 that's when it was like I said
right in the middle of the Civil War so
let's talk a little bit about the stuff
about the quote-unquote pilgrims they
were not called that at the time they
weren't called that until later who came
over on the Mayflower and how all that
[ __ ] went down and then how that led up
to like the Thanksgiving thing so you
know the story goes and like we were
taught in school
here come the pilgrims in on the
Mayflower they land on Plymouth Rock you
know they set up their little settlement
or whatever now something that I didn't
actually know until much later was that
they actually were not supposed to land
in Massachusetts that weren't that
wasn't where they were heading they were
actually going to Virginia but they
[ __ ] up so when they landed at
Plymouth Rock that was like the wrong
place yeah I don't think they were the
first ones there was other ones there
were other colonies that landed weren't
well I think Jamestown was before that
but that was kind of like the first
permanent settlement I think that was
only a couple years before um yeah so
the Europeans they first go to New
England in like the mid 16 tens right
around them but when they first got
there like the whole coast was just like
it was all Native American settlements
it was so crowded that there was like no
room for anyone else to settle in there
because they had taken up like all the
good land obviously because there were a
lot of them living there but and we
probably mentioned this before like when
the Europeans like came back again most
of those Native Americans were dead
because there had been some kind of like
disease like a plague or like that they
still really don't know what caused that
you're pretty sure it was the Spanish
the arrival of the Spanish probably sick
oh well they were carrying European
disease and they didn't have any
immunities no defense yeah yeah so yeah
so by the time the Europeans came back
that's like there was just like all
these like empty settlements because
most of the Native Americans that they
had seen previously like on their
previous journey was we're dead you know
this was only like a three year period
I remember reading one thing where there
was
somebody during this era sailing up the
coastline and at night you could
actually see like a red glow
they said through the heavens lighting
up all the trees yeah all the campfires
mm-hmm it was like a cityscape yeah and
that's it that's how many Indians there
were yeah and they actually did a study
trying to figure out how much would they
were burdened and evidently they were
doing a hell ecological destruction I
think it's out there that a certain
amount of wood every day well yeah yeah
yeah and there weren't planting they
were just cut and but before that big
play get hit and I think that's when
that guy saw that saw the tree line yeah
because I think you mentioned that later
on a few years later that was gone yeah
because like I said this was kind of
like I think was around 16 14 16 15 when
they first like I said there was no
place for them to settle because it was
just Kratts it was packed they said
there was just settlements everywhere
yeah before that before that plague they
said it was just like packed and they
said that this if the forest looked
manicured and think you know and it was
laid out for displayed so I bet you they
were running through people's forest
their gardens yeah and what do you call
him fields and crops yeah as they were
in that area
agricultural yeah there were different
plant and stuff yeah so just like that
one thing that we read in there what was
it cracked magazine yeah they weren't
they weren't uncivilized savages they
had no of course not
they had to have technology they were
quite advanced well like I said they
were the ones that had to like teach the
pilgrims I'll get to later on they
taught them like how to fish and they
taught them how to like grow the crops
that were native to there because the
pilgrims didn't have any idea what they
were doing there's a lot of mysterious
stuff in the United States tunnels that
can't be explained things that looked
kind of like old weathered pyramids and
they were building down here and went
but when that plague dot went when that
plague got a lot of them a lot of stuff
was lost oh yeah because they built
stuff we just don't know we just you
know don't know what it means or who did
it yeah there's like there's still so
much [ __ ] there's like all those weird
and stuff that they're not real sure
like where the [ __ ] came from it's like
there's so much of it that still has to
be yeah and stuff that looks man-made
and it's in it still it's big yeah
they're not sure who did it yeah but
there were stuff going on back then oh
yeah yeah but yeah so um you know so
within three years like a lot of the
Native American tribes have been wiped
out by you know some plague or disease
or whatever that they still haven't
identified so when the settlers came
back again like in the late sixteen tens
they basically found like all these
settlements that were just like eerily
empty they were like kind of like ghost
town type of thing so they kind of just
said about - raiding the place you know
raiding the corpses for clothes and yeah
stuff because they figured hey what's
practical I guess so September 1620
there's a merchant ship called The
Mayflower and it's set sail from
Plymouth England now this was normally
not a passenger ship this was normally a
cargo ship it usually carried dry goods
and wine there were 102 passengers on
here and 40 of them were Protestant
separatists they called themselves
Saints these are the people that would
later be called the pilgrims so what
they wanted to do was establish a church
in the new world where they could you
know kind of worship the way they wanted
to because they were trying to kind of
get away from from the church and
getting to secular and to worldly over
there it wasn't even so much that they
thought that they were well it's a yeah
it's more cobbled kind of get it I think
I had to do with the Protestant Catholic
conflicts and yeah see because what
ended up happening was so so these
people prior to this in 1608 a bunch of
these Protestants had moved to Holland
because they thought they would be able
to have more religious freedom there
which they did however they didn't like
Holland because it was to quote unquote
cosmopolitan for them a little too
secular and they just they didn't like
it they thought it was too freewheeling
and laid-back and they just couldn't
hang they had to have that
uptight lifestyle so they couldn't deal
with the people in Holland so even
though Holland we're all like yeah even
though people in Holland are probably
just all laying around smoking by
coaches but you know so the English
people were just like no we can't have
that their little collars we're too
stiff so pretty much yes see they had a
thing where they didn't want to pledge
allegiance to the Church of England
because they saw the Church of England
as just as corrupt as the Catholic
Church you know I mean so they didn't
like either one of them and they just
wanted to like part ways and start their
own [ __ ] you know it's just like
American product process today yeah that
same thing similar yeah now there's a
church the state they were worried about
all that yeah so I mean when you're
talking about pilgrims like I said they
weren't called that at the time you're
not these are not Puritans that was a
different thing but so these people who
like I said they called themselves
Saints who were essentially separatists
so after they stayed in Holland for a
while and then they were just like you
know [ __ ] this it's just too worldly and
they just couldn't deal with it even
though they were allowed to worship as
they wanted cuz I guess the Dutch didn't
really care but one thing that they
couldn't do when they were in Holland is
I guess that because they were
immigrants the Dutch wouldn't let them
into like the trade guilds and stuff so
the jobs that they had they couldn't get
like any really good jobs they had to
kind of do like kind of crappy ones and
they sort of weren't happy about that
also some of their kids were leaving the
sect because they liked the Dutch
lifestyle cuz like I said they were a
little more worldly and they seemed like
more fun shell I guess so like the kids
were starting to leave so the Saints
were kind of like yeah we can't really
have that so we have to get the [ __ ] out
they were probably realistic not
idealistic they go man we're gonna go to
the New World and get our asses [ __ ]
killed rather stay here read well yeah
that's the thing I mean you're
volunteering for hardship to say yes
that these policies not entirely sure
like these religious separates I think
you kind of gotta either be dumb or kind
of nuts to do to to do or a combination
of yeah yeah yeah or just because
I don't think that I don't think the
rewards would outweigh the risks well
I'm not really entirely sure how I mean
obviously they were not prepared for
going to the new world I don't think
they knew what it was going to be like
they were guessing I mean I I don't
think that they imagined like the
hardship that they would encounter when
they got there like I'm not I'm not sure
what exactly they were thinking but it's
like they were thinking it was gonna
they were gonna do they think they were
just gonna like land on on US shores and
that's like go to the Starbucks and
that's like everyone would like give
them like a parade and [ __ ] they were
gonna land in a paradise it was gonna be
kind of like something out of the book
of Genesis like even there's not like
maybe that's what it was and it would be
very light very much like a garden or
like you know like a field out out and
in England somewhere between two towns
yeah and you're just like gonna picnic
and camp it may be like yeah I mean
raised some sheep or something you know
and maybe like plant plant a few things
and everything would be fine that's what
I mean the thing about it though is that
some some Europeans had been to the new
world they knew what it was like so you
think that that some information about
that might have filtered back to them I
think a lot of them weren't there never
came back yeah a lot of some of those
colonies just vanished that's true yeah
well I think about that couldn't just go
on the internet and you know see what
happened Anu world know that what
happened to this colony and when did
they leave yeah call yeah so I think it
was rumor and entail and you know in
that era with those type of people with
that type of education and limited
amount of information and the
imagination might be able to run wild
with you but if you're religious yeah so
you gonna look at this in biblical terms
they probably thought God will provide
I will provide Adobe just
like eating you know because they
thought they were right in the religious
views so they thought well God will give
us a place that we can go maybe they
were thinking and get attacked by a
bunch of bunch of natives it'll be just
like David versus Goliath and we'll you
know we'll try a prevail will prevail
just by our goodness you know I imagine
that power I think that was my own
thinking and they get there and they
realized it they're like oh [ __ ] yeah
first of all I realize that they're not
prepared that they're weaker than
Indians that's another thing that the
yeah that it is the Indians pretty you
had to pretty much run with the Indians
to impress them and they weren't scared
of gods yeah there's a lot of [ __ ]
things that people modern-day people
think they're myths
Indians had no respect for guns because
guns sucked in those days well yeah they
were matchlocks yeah which were [ __ ]
useless
there was like a pop gun and then you
know the match would go out and powder
would get wet and they didn't really
even make a good Club reloading time was
a lot yeah but and they weren't accurate
at all they were smoothbore you got off
one round you usually missed and the
guys ran up on you with something like a
wall I got like a war club and just beat
you to death that's nicely how that [ __ ]
went down yeah it was a European weapon
used for scarring you know I mean yeah
it was just not something that worked in
the New World
well and another thing too is that when
the Europeans came here they had no
familiarity with the terrain or the
climate or anything like that so in that
way the Native Americans had a huge
advantage yeah like not only were their
weapons like they had bows and arrows
had been like that they had better
weapons and weapon clothes you know but
they were more suited to the terrain
they that they'd lived there for
thousands of years so they were like
used to it yeah I mean oh uh firearms
didn't become good weapons until the
1800s yeah with the advent of the
metallic cartridge yeah you you can you
know you could say that some
muzzleloading rifles and cap block type
pistols you know from you know that
before that they were okay yeah the very
very late versions of the muzzleloading
black-powder stuff but really
it wasn't until the metallic case came
out you know that weapons were any good
yeah that was about mid eighteen
hundreds before that time you were
better off with a really good bow or a
sword or something like that yeah but
this Europeans had to have it a carrying
them yeah and they're there like you did
looking at it's looking at civil war you
know they're using kind of Napoleonic
fighting tactics and let's line up there
they line up load up your guns let's
shoot at that big old crowd over there
yeah you know don't you lay down on the
ground
[Laughter]
honor you couldn't I get that I can got
down on the ground and Dodger for
anything that was [ __ ] don't you late
you get up and let me do stand-up in
that volley face him like a man crazy
[ __ ] man it's crazy yeah it's like oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] camouflage I'm wearing red
yeah I want everybody to see me yeah
yeah yeah big bright target yeah I
always like oh they were inaccurate so
you yeah they were inaccurate weapons
probably was you had to aim at a dam you
can you could hit a barn and that's what
they'd be to make it fair you had a
group basically to rock concerts kind of
shooting at each other you're hitting
here somewhere generals yelling yeah you
guys got shot up okay you know I'm going
back right now and then you got lucky
and yeah but yeah so we'll each other
pieces yeah it was just those where
those generals were trained but he needs
didn't fight that way they sensibly yeah
it's like guerrilla tactics that's why a
lot of their early battles and some like
that they won though is because Indians
mostly won battles yeah and like I said
we'll get into that a little bit talk
about the Pequot War but uh yeah so so
these separatists you know they're in
Holland they're not getting the good
jobs their kids are taking off and like
yeah we just you know we're gonna hang
with the with the Dutch because they
seem like chill and everything so they
said okay well we're gonna go to the new
world just like I said not even
expecting I don't even
so they go back to London to get to kind
of get their [ __ ] together poor they go
to the New World
so there's this guy and he's like a
merchant who has like a [ __ ] ton of
money and he says okay well I'll give
you an advance to go you know to go over
there so they get permission from the
Virginia company to establish a
plantation on the east coast of Virginia
it was supposed to be between 38 and 41
degrees north latitude which is about
between Chesapeake Bay and the mouth of
the Hudson River that's what they were
supposed to be going
however as history shows that's not
where they ended up but that's what they
were supposed to go and that's where
they had permission to go and permission
to set up a settlement now the King of
England gave them permission to go and
said they could leave the Church of
England as long as they heard the quote
was provided they carried themselves
peaceably yeah yeah you guys just
chilled out now so August of 1620
there's these forty Saints now what a
lot of people don't know - is that the
quote-unquote pilgrims that came over on
the Mayflower they weren't all these
religious separatists some of them were
just like regular ass people who were
trying to get away from England for
various reasons some of them because
they were had a lot of debt or because
they were poor and they didn't think
that they could do you know they weren't
doing that well in England they said
thought maybe I'll go over there and
start over and [ __ ] like that so there
there were other like motives for people
it wasn't all you know religious freedom
or whatever now the other people that
were on the ship who were kind of more
secular were called strangers that's
what the Saints called them so they
actually set sail from Southampton in
two boats the Mayflower and the
Speedwell however they didn't get that
far before the Speedwell sprung a leak
so they both had to turn around and go
back and then all the people on
Speedwell had to get onto Mayflower
now unfortunately and like I said
there's a lot of people it's a cargo
ship it wasn't really that big it was 80
feet long and 24 feet wide so yeah so
they were kind of crammed into this boat
and the problem was because of because
the speed wall had sprung a leak and
they had to go back that delayed their
trip to such an extent that by the time
they say
started sailing the Atlantic Ocean it
was like this stormy season so it was
like the shitty time of year when no one
wanted to sail because like I said
they've been running late so it actually
ended up taking more than two months and
they said the journey was just horrific
they said pretty much everybody was
seasick like the entire time one of the
guys who was one of the quote-unquote
strangers got swept overboard you know
and [ __ ] like that I love that like what
the I think he was like the governor of
the Plymouth Colony later on William
Bradford and he was the one where he
wrote so much about the Plymouth Colony
later on this world like a lot of the
stuff that we know about the Plymouth
Colony comes from his writings he said
the one guy that's got swept overboard I
love this [ __ ] quote disgust it
should take he says it was the just hand
of God upon him okay for the young
sailor had been a proud and very profane
yeah God punished him by sweeping him
out that he was proud of just where God
took him out yeah like you flick and he
just like licked him up [ __ ] back
and swept him into the ocean where he
probably got eaten by sharks but I'm
like I love that that dude was just kind
of like where you just like poopies over
there rolling around so yeah so 66 days
it took him to cross the ocean like I
said everyone's puking over the sides it
was horrible they're all crammed in this
boat so they finally get there and like
I said even though they were supposed to
land like near Chesapeake Bay or the
Hudson River they actually ended up
landing at what is now called Plymouth
Rock yeah so that yeah so they ended up
in the wrong place and not only that but
this was somewhere where they didn't
have permission to be because as I said
they had permission to go to this one
place in Virginia
ever this is Massachusetts so they're
not really allowed to be here so they
decide well we came all this way and it
sucked so we're just gonna stay so you
know and and it was like I said a lot of
the Native American tribes had been
wiped out by disease and stuff like that
so there wasn't a lot of you know there
were some settlements that have been
abandoned so they started kind of
raiding it for supplies and raiding the
graves and stuff for supplies so they
named the colony Plymouth 40 one of the
saints and strangers then drafted a
document that they called the Mayflower
Compact and this was supposedly you know
they're saying we're gonna have the laws
we're gonna all abide by the laws in
yada yada it's just like making it
official or whatever they also swore
their allegiance to the English king
then so you know they they get there now
the first winter they were there like I
said they seemed to have I don't know
what they were expecting but they really
seemed to have no idea of what the
climate was gonna be like they didn't
really have enough supplies they didn't
have enough food so they spent like the
first winter when they got there they
actually spent it on the boat and a
whole bunch of them died you know
probably about I think it was about half
of them warmer up in that boat I guess
almost all the women died I think there
was like nineteen women and I think all
but five of them yeah five of them lives
they know where they were through that
winter yeah I feel like they had no idea
like what the [ __ ] was going on they
knew how to make an igloo know that like
I said they just came over here yeah I
don't know what they thought was gonna
happen it's like I just really I just
really don't sounds crazy they make a
house out of damn snow and I stay to be
warm but no he can get very warm and
said well yeah why do you think yeah
yeah probably better than that boat yeah
well I mean they did stay in the boat
but a lot of them died anyway it wasn't
just um it wasn't just from the cold
some of them starved to death because
like I said they didn't have enough
supplies I bet you a lot of clothes
disease yeah they're cookin you see you
got to spread out yeah just [ __ ] like
staff ya can start spreading like crazy
yeah and that might have been what it
was because they were all just cramped
they've been crammed together in this
[ __ ] boat like all sick in every
their lifetime so go we don't Boyle's
happened and then you know historians
will will come up Wilson got a
mysterious disease just struck them down
lot of that [ __ ] sounds like staph yeah
good staff spread like can spread like
crazy oh yeah they still have problems
with it now in hospitals and stuff you
got people real close together to work
it hard to get cuts on them in huh
there's sneezing and wiping their nose
and putting boogers on [ __ ] ok button
book your session it touching stuff and
touching and wiping their eyes with
their hand and people touching
scratching and touch it [ __ ] spreads
like I said their nose in their ass yeah
[Laughter]
neither washing machine machines nor
sense yeah you're probably right about
yeah I always wondered too if like the
Native Americans thought that either
like look at this disgusting [ __ ] yeah
they're all sucking riddled with lice
and I said they were weak they're a weak
and childlike and they treated their
women like children and there's a lot of
Indian stuff that I dread yeah they were
totally like a fish out of water yeah
basically basically they were saying
they were just nerdy real nerdy
restricted kind of people that good had
to do things a certain way that you know
Indians reversible they're practical
well yeah and like I said they've been
living in this environment thousands of
years and it's like they had kind of a
thing yeah it up you know what I mean if
you read [ __ ] written by white people
all through that entire period really
through the entire period there was an
it was nothing but just one long man
Shawnee Indians yeah that's all they
wrote about how great Indians were that
all this [ __ ] was better well yeah I
mean it's like I know where he's getting
you know they get these some of these
people today think there was some kind
of weird racial hatred go back and go
read what white people were writing
about Indians yes it was [ __ ]
admiration most you know almost all yeah
because they were so like huge to bigger
stronger yeah they had their [ __ ]
together
yeah they had better stuff they had
better stuff you know they lived the
Europeans were admitting that they lived
a better lifestyle it was a word there
was clean country living on the road
moving around that they were
better-looking just everything that you
could imagine just totally brown-nosing
on these Indians I think they were
telling the truth yeah they said they
were superior physical specimens yeah
and that's why so many white people
joined Indian tribes that you know some
most tribes were damn near white well I
would feel like if I got that was the
place to be if I got dragged over here
back then yeah um you know I think
that's probably the first thing I would
have done they had white people joining
him in runaway slaves join an Indian
tribes it was just you know like I said
you can Indians didn't really Indians
Indians evidently weren't too prejudiced
if they liked it if they liked you
thought you were worth [ __ ] they'd let
you join yeah yeah but yeah so as I said
these first settlers that came over on
the Mayflower they spent the first
winter on the ship about half of them
died from disease malnutrition various
other things in April of 1621 the
Mayflower had to go back to England so
they kind of like they said well
colonists you just have to stay here now
you have to like make the settlement so
they did now it seems that probably if
the Native Americans if some of the
Native Americans had not like stepped
forward to help these poor helpless
people then probably all of them would
have died I think you know to me because
they had no [ __ ] clue they just came
over here that anything so here is a guy
named Samoset he was from the Pawtuxet
tribe and he approached them and
speak English they were very surprised
through him he helped the colonists kind
of form an alliance with the local tribe
the Wampanoag and he actually ended up
teaching them how to hunt all the local
animals how to grow corn beans squash
gather shellfish and fish and stuff like
that because apparently the college
didn't even know how to do that and all
this other kind of stuff now there is
also the very famous Squanto which was
actually not his name his name was TSK
wantem Squanto was actually just kind of
like a nickname that somebody gave him
and that for some reason that's the one
that stuck even though tisk want him is
like a way more badass yeah so um he
also approached the pilgrims and offered
to help them he was fluent in English
and that was because he had been in
about 16 14 16 15 he had actually been
captured along with many other Native
Americans and taken back to England and
sold as a slave he actually escaped at
one point and came back to the new world
but then he got captured again I think
and then they took him to Spain and has
sold him into slavery but he escaped to
England and then came back to the new
world so he you know so he was very
familiar with like English traditions
like I said he was fluent in English so
he acted as the the separatists
translator and also taught him how to
plant corn and various other types of
things read some stuff about him though
he he wasn't really a slave slave they
didn't they didn't capture him and and
they didn't capture him and turn him
into a worker what they did is they just
took him around and showed him off they
did that a lot yeah because I feel like
they did that's a hot sauce yeah he was
he was like they brought him to England
and used him kind of like a an
attraction yeah or what would be a good
way to put it
like a like a museum piece yeah look
what we got because he went and met the
royal family and he was free he could
walk around he'd evidently had some kids
while he was there
quickly on one of those trips yeah I
don't know and he he wore British
clothes and adapted to the to the
culture and everything could speak
English then every time he'd go back
home to the United States and meet the
Indians he tried to describe England to
them and they didn't believe him yeah he
was tripping I was tripping he met the
king and the Queen and that you know
that they lived in stone houses and he
tried to describe to them what cities
like and they thought it was they
thought he's lying there like [ __ ]
yeah tell us another one pull the other
one and I think the second time I think
he kind of went back voluntarily yeah I
think if I remember correctly that's an
oversimplified version of there's more
to it than that yeah like I said they
don't know a lot about they know that he
was captured at least once maybe twice I
think he was captured he was captured
what they would do a lot of times and
this pride how they got him is they
didn't fight it got me to invite an
Indian on the ship to show him the ship
you know I mean they were friends and
then they'd be like never sailing yeah
clamp the irons on him and sail off
that's not and then once they got out of
view of the land they'd take the irons
off of them and say you're with us now
and they'd be crying and you know and
they'd try to cheer him up you know what
I mean but they didn't think anything of
it let's take him England that's so
weird to me it's like they didn't they
didn't think that this was like a person
that had like a family and I guess don't
care they're like we're gonna get over
it yeah go over it be alright we did it
because they're sailors yeah yeah we did
it you know get over a l'heure I got
shame yeah yeah well he has nothing
shanghainese shanghai white people so
they came back on wake up you're in
Shanghai uh yeah they were [ __ ] they
basically shanghaied you yeah well yeah
and when like I said he got sold into
slavery in Spain and then he escaped and
went to England and then by the time he
got back to the New World
hit all of his people were dead they
were dead and that bled him that plague
yeah so he had missed that whole thing
was another story I heard about one that
was living there in England he got two
he lived the high life while he was
there as a as like like a museum exhibit
and I'm pretty sure I pretty sure I read
this I don't know if my imagine he got
back to the New World in a rowboat or a
small sailboat
I wonder he stole it yeah stole it like
the harbor a small boat and came back on
his own [ __ ] man that's hardcore dude
huh had his looking and brought his
supplies and everything you know so he'd
planned for the trip yeah but I think it
was a rowboat with a sail on can you
imagine
yeah I mean I know it's been done yeah
he went he made it back to the new world
on that [ __ ] man yeah I think it was a
robo his sail that's good he'd planned
for it you know he had his water and all
his [ __ ] you know he wasn't dumb I'm
gonna set on a few month journey across
the Atlantic Ocean yes kind of balls you
need yeah you really want to go back
home big giant brass balls yeah well
maybe like I kind of feel like if you're
in a situation like that it's probably
like well I really don't want to say I
don't want to stay here like bad enough
that I would rather like die out in the
ocean yeah like to risk getting back
home which you know one of the audience
remembers members might remember what it
is I'm thinking of yeah because I'm
fairly sure that I was not a fiction
that that was real yeah but yeah so
squanto comes back like I said he comes
back to the new world in 1619 after
escaping from slavery in Europe and
found out that all of his people had
been killed by disease now he like I
said he was born into the pot toxic
tribe but when he got back all his
people were gone so he moved in with the
Wampanoag tribe and he gets brought to
the pilgrim settlement in spring of 1916
21 rather he comes with Samoset and like
I said because he was fluent in English
he was actually kind of not adopted but
the Governor William Bradford the same
guy he was talking about think I get
swept off the boat earlier he actually
made him is idiot Indian emissary and
like his translator and whatnot and he
also was instrumental in helping the
in their negotiations with masa so it it
was the chief of the Wampanoag so they
were kind of like you know trying to
come to a peace or whatever now it's
right around here
where the first what they call today the
first Thanksgiving took place right
around this time now it was the end of
the summer of 1621
that you get because it being at the end
of November that didn't happen to like a
lot later they think that these that
this first Thanksgiving probably took
place probably in late September or
maybe October some sources I've said say
probably it was around summer September
29th because that was Michaelmas so that
might have been like the best time to do
it so this was the first one that they
had it was supposedly a three-day
festival um
weirdly they because they were kind of
celebrating the you know like the
pilgrims had got their [ __ ] together
with the help of the Native Americans
who were like here dummies like let me
show you how to like fish and like plant
[ __ ] and everything so they actually had
like a really good harvest so they were
celebrating that the weird thing about
it is that I don't think that the Native
Americans were actually invited but they
just kind of showed up and they're not
really sure why they showed up they they
think maybe it was some kind of like
they were doing some kind of negotiation
or something and they just kind of
happened to show but it's like hey you
guys have a party needed advice what the
[ __ ] so it's like but there were
actually more Native Americans at the
quote-unquote Thanksgiving than pilgrims
there were actually 90 Native Americans
there and probably only about 50 53
pilgrims so the the Native Americans
brought five deer that they had killed
to add to the feast or whatever um you
know and there was kind of like like I
said they they have some cuz William
Bradford who wrote a lot about [ __ ] that
you know happened around the time he
kind of wrote a lot about it and was
saying how they had turned up with the
deer and he was saying like what all the
foods were that they had they don't
think that they had turkey um there
might have been some wild turkey but
that was kind of like um that yeah they
said waterfowl yeah was one of the first
things that they said also a lot of
fish shellfish Lobster that kind of
stuff maybe eel that kind of stuff but
some of the stuff that we consider like
Thanksgiving food nowadays like squash
pumpkin you know that kind of stuff they
did have that because that was you know
food that was native to that area and
that's why we still eat it largely like
nowadays so so the holiday that we think
of as Thanksgiving big T Thanksgiving
it's weird because what we traditionally
think of is like the first Thanksgiving
that one with like the Pilgrims and the
Indians and like they had to which did
happen but they didn't really I don't
think they really gave it much
historical significance at the time I
think that kind of came later because
you have to imagine that the word
Thanksgiving they had like other
Thanksgiving ceremonies like anytime
there was like some big cool event or
you know something awesome happened so
they had like a day of Thanksgiving like
or feasting or whatever to celebrate so
there was more than one you know what I
mean so they didn't even really refer to
the one that the famous one that
happened in 1621 they didn't even really
refer to that as like Thanksgiving until
later on because there was one from 1541
you know that was just like a general
Thanksgiving you know yeah good should
happened the first mention of actually
the word Thanksgiving with a small T in
early colonial history didn't come about
till 1623 and this was this is just to
show you how common this [ __ ] was right
so that year 1623 the pilgrims like all
summer had been this horrible horrible
drought it had been like two or three
months long and they spent an entire day
in July fasting and praying for it to
rain and the next day guess what
it rained like hot just lightly and also
on the I believe on the same day a ship
arrived from the Netherlands with more
settlers and more supplies so they just
thought that was the coolest thing ever
and that it was God's providence or
whatever so they said well we have to
have like a Thanksgiving celebration for
that and that's what they called it but
that was the first time that that word
been used like in early colonial
writings and that was two years after
like the famous one but so like I'm
saying that you know they didn't impart
this big historical significance at the
time because they did them all the time
like every time that was a good harvest
every time like I said they prayed and
it rained
you know they decided that they would
celebrate it or whatever there was also
another one in 1631
they thought there was this ship that
was supposed to be coming that with
supplies and they thought it was lost at
sea and then it pulled into the harbor
and they were like woot and then think
that a Thanksgiving for that as well so
you know and there were ones even before
that there were some ones like in the
1540s it was one in Texas there was one
in st. Augustine Florida also in the
1500s so this is something that kind of
and usually it's a religious kind of
thing usually these are either
associated with feasting sometimes they
do fasting as well because like I said
it's usually like religious or like
they're giving thanks to God for you
know doing some [ __ ] for them and [ __ ]
like that so you know the practice of
having a Thanksgiving like every year
like around the same time it did kind of
start to come together like in the mid
1600s like in New England like around
but in the south not so much it didn't
really take hold until later on it was
more a New England thing like during the
1600s like around Connecticut and stuff
and they would kind of start having
these kind of feasts every year like to
celebrate harvests and whatnot so I
think we are probably going to take a
break at the moment and then when we
come back I want to talk about more kind
of more like darker side of Thanksgiving
in colonial history I want to talk about
the Pequot War you know which happened a
few years after the supposedly famous
Thanksgiving and that was pretty
horrible also talk about some
cannibalism that went on in early
colonial America talked about the first
official murderer the first guy that was
executed for murder in colonial America
which I just found out today so we'll
kind of talk about that too when we come
back from the break and we will be back
in just a minute
you love true crime I love true crime
and I've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing
unsolved murders of the 20th century
it's called the faceless villain and
volume three is available now featuring
such fascinating cases as the Caddy
murders the carry baby's case the Frog
Boys the al-qasr murders and the
inokashira park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain volume three is an
involving exploration of unsolved slang
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or eBook
formats on Amazon or download the
audiobook version from audible.com and
get ready for a chilling journey through
modern crime history
yeah and so look at the beat she just
loves me I don't know
bare feet shoe she's okay get my running
shoes okay what why are you doing that
why you eat in a box
wait in the box all chef so it eats
everything she's like a little goat
you're like a little goat and all that
yeah you can't help it that's just how
you do I know you're the funniest
kidding she's like yeah you gonna eat
mama sheep oh look oh oh here comes the
other one
here comes beiges she wants in on the
action too she wants in on the action
what do you think about that booty what
do you think about that you don't think
much of it do ya
I can tell by the look on your face
uh-oh Oh confrontation conflict conflict
Oh a peaceful resolution uh well not now
cuz oh she can't resist it
what are you guys gonna do what are you
guys gonna do nothing
looked like oh oh oh
puppy
war
acting casual okay
you didn't even swipe it Beijing's but
what a good girl you are visually wins
this round right we're back during the
break we were talking about all the
different stuff that we were gonna make
ahead for Thanksgiving and I said you
know I was reading the Wikipedia page
about the traditional Thanksgiving meal
and stuff like that because it feel like
90% of Americans probably eat like you
know the traditional like turkey
stuffing gravy Stefon Stefon I already
said that pumpkin pie all that kind of
stuff but evidently if you have like
different you know if you yeah if your
ancestors were immigrants from different
parts of the world they each have their
own little saying that they add to it
because I didn't really know this but
apparently Italian Americans and please
you know if you are one let me know
we'll have the traditional Thanksgiving
dinner but they also have a big-ass
lasagna oh yeah so they consider lasagna
like kind of like a Thanksgiving dinner
I'm like that's a big old family food
yeah you can make a bunch of it's
delicious it is yes we make lasagna a
lot I mean what when you look at that
when you look at the Thanksgiving - the
traditional Thanksgiving food there's a
turkey gravy dressing potatoes potatoes
yams some corn yeah they're the all the
the cranberry stuff which is sometimes
mixed with nuts you can really see like
an Anglo influence to that yeah that's
it that's an angry it's really the only
American meal when you think about it
everything else came from somewhere else
yeah because then even the hamburger I
think is but I think that's more German
its German yeah but but that's uniquely
American but you can see that that
recipe is written by damn British people
yeah or people with British tastes and
come and is you could say culinary
heritage yeah but that's what they
that's that's like something personal
well it's kind of something like because
even nowadays you know when like when
they have like the British like the the
crisps
dinner which is more like our
Thanksgiving except they don't do like
pumpkin stuff and I mean they might now
but since everything's kind of more
globalized and everything but you know
pumpkin squash you know beans that's
kind of like North America yeah
type stuff so so you could see how
that's versatile anybody everybody likes
head meal pretty much I think how can
you not yeah I think you know a few if
it's done if it's cooked correctly and
if it's in the right context I think
anybody would like that meal but I could
see you know if I was Italian I'd say
like yeah it's great but where's the
lasagna pizza it's just kind of like
people that cuz my sister does too but
it's like on Christmas it's like she
doesn't really like go in for like the
Christmas dinner of things it's like
some people go to like trying to go get
Chinese food on Christmas and that's
like a Christmas tradition to go get you
a Spanish family pie one big ol piece of
footage salted fish where's that big ol
of with them they probably do that yeah
well cause like I said it's you know I
feel like a lot of you know people even
people that came from immigrant families
which most of us did um you know kind of
but you add your own kind of like
cultural flavor to it
which I never really thought that much
about because you know like I said my
background is generally Irish English
and Native Americans so you know we kind
of always had that traditional just
Turkey potatoes you know pumpkin pie all
that kind of stuff but so we never had
like any weird additions yeah you know
what I mean like yeah I do too well he
makes a really good lasagna I love all
that Italian food Italian American food
yeah some of the someone's recipes that
are from Italy are kind of sparse to me
there's there's a lot of fish in them a
lot of seafood now well I like seafood
though yeah
but this it's it's real fishy yeah yeah
I mean I I like fish but it's got to be
kind of like a mild fish yeah you know
Brazil yeah I like Brazilian Italian
food it's like Italian food yeah there's
a lot of like things like squid inside
your your your your pasta not much sauce
it ends up being just kind of fishy and
salty tasting I'm not really into that
flavor profile yeah but you know it's
still good I think if you ask me though
Italian American food is better than the
day but in a lot of cases because
Italians came here and ones that ones
that did immigrated here came from
poverty when they got around all these
like we just want to eat all the food
we're hungry they got around all these
groceries they took that [ __ ] to an
extreme that's that could be the motto
of the United States we take everything
from where you came from you just come
here and just blow it up to show it is
power so the Italian Americans took like
poor people food from Sicily and Italy
but then made it rich people food by
[ __ ] putting lots of tomatoes on it
lots of [ __ ] garlic and lots of
cheese and lots yeah that's that's real
active it locks
that's the name a game with Italian food
really just a lot of it yeah lots of it
and I know you Italians a Italian
Americans out there could agree if I can
tell you how to [ __ ] me they do yeah
yeah well and that's I I really like
this that's kind of part of their
culture it's like where everybody gets
together it's like a big family and it's
like every bit like they just have this
massive like plate really get a table
for food and you can't separate [ __ ]
Italians from steak houses steak house I
also love stays know what's good baby
[Laughter]
honestly I like all the food I'll eat it
all I don't care what it is Bri there's
very few things that I won't eat I
should have a say yeah I should have
been Italian [ __ ] right you do kind of
come up
you gotta come up you see like a little
bit of a gangster he could have been
like yeah should have been Italian you
should have been like an Italian
American gangster like well I guess what
are you doing I would have been the
Irish that's what they would have called
me because they're you know is a a crazy
[ __ ] Irish dude that was with them
yeah every little mafia he was like the
token yeah all right so let's talk a
little bit about I wanted to talk a
little bit about the Pequot War because
like I said this is something that you
know because in 1621 when the pilgrims
in the you know the Indians got together
and had the Thanksgiving dinner and
everything like that I think that they
kind of like a lot of particularly you
know in school and stuff like that they
kind of leave you hanging with the store
and be like oh and then everything was
okay but that's not really how she I
mean that the peace did not last very
long it was only like a few years later
that the Pequot War broke out so we're
gonna talk about that a little bit and
you look like you want to say yeah I can
see I can see that every [ __ ] tell
you dude I knew in our mentions we were
tied [ __ ] okay you're an honorary our
does haven't kind that growing growing
up partially in Brazil yeah make sure
Brazil and Mississippi it ends up
looking a lot like a baby that's because
that is kind of a strange it's yeah all
right so the Pequot War was something
that I don't even actually even remember
learning about this in school but it
only happened a few years after they
very famous first Thanksgiving in in
1636 and
scene 37 now so what ended up happening
was that the Pequot tears the Pequot
tribe their territory was about 250
square miles in what is now southeastern
Connecticut now during the early 17th
century there were approximately 8,000
Pequot men women and children living in
this particular territory and they had
like a lot of power and influence like
over some of the other tribes in the
area and why not now in 1633 and 1634
there was a smallpox epidemic and half
of the Pequot tribe died so the 1620s
the dutch were already here and the
Dutch and the Pequot tribe controlled
pretty much all the trade in the region
now the Pequot were kind of like trying
to lord it over other tribes like I said
like they had like a lot of power
between them and the Dutch and they had
actually by 1635 they had extended their
kind of political power by various
things in her marriage
you know warfare fairies other things
now the Pequot War which broke out in
1636 as I said that was actually the
Pequot people fighting against a
coalition of English settlers from
Massachusetts Bay the Connecticut and
Saybrook colonies and the English also
had Native American just like we were
saying before they had Native American
allies the Narragansett tribe and the
Mohegan Tribe we're fighting on the side
of the English against the Pequod so
like I said this is a lot more
complicated because some of the Indian
tribes were fighting with the Europeans
against other Native American yeah and
here's another thing this is this will
this will do teach you something about
extraterrestrial communication and the
problem the reason why a lot of these
Indian Wars had busted out is because we
white man would meet the white man would
make an alliance with an Indian tribe
and as soon as that happened the other
Indian tribes that were not in that
allies got [ __ ] paranoid
that that Indian tribe would get
preferential treatment yeah in terms of
trade deals money and weaponry so they
would they would wig the [ __ ] out and
and and and and try to fight you know I
mean to try to stop an alliance or to
get in on alliance or to wipe out a
[ __ ] enemy Indian tribe before that
Alliance had taken root it was [ __ ] like
that when you started getting involved
in international politics like that
there's always blowback yeah you do what
you think is the right thing hey we're
gonna be in a lot we're gonna make an
alliance with this tribe turns out that
tribe had enemies yeah that's what
happened well and that's what happened
in this situation I mean the thing about
it is that you know at the point where
the English first arrived like I said
you know the you know the Pequot and the
Dutch they have like a huge stake in
like all the trading and stuff like that
particularly the fur trade also wampum
which was you know the beads and
everything so they kind of controlled
the whole trade so there was a lot of
other Native American tribes that were
resentful of the Pequot because they
felt that they were kind of like lording
it over them and they didn't really like
it because they were like controlling
all the trade in the area so when the
English showed up some of the Native
American tribes were trying to get in
with them where we're trying to kind of
like hey you know why don't you guys
fight with us against these guys cuz
these guys have been like you know
stepping on our dicks like all this time
we don't like it so that was so there
were like tension simmering for a long
time before war actually broke out now
so then there were like a couple of
incidents that occurred that kind of
pushed you know the whole situation
toward war one of these was the murder
of a trader named Johnstone and his
entire crew they were actually killed on
the Connecticut River by the Pequot in
1634 now they're not entirely sure why
this guy was killed the Pequot
apparently had their reasons they felt
that they were justified in killing him
but because he was an Englishman the
English were kind of like okay well we
can't let that [ __ ] slide like we can't
make it look like oh the Native
Americans couldn't go around killing
English people willy-nilly so that kind
of you know the tensions between you
know the English and the Pequod started
building up even more and more and then
there was another trader named John
Oldham who was also found murdered on
his ship off Block Island which is now
near Rhode Island and that was in July
of 1636
now this time I'm not sure I don't think
they were Pequod Indians but they were
missis Indians but this cut these two
murders like happening in sequence you
know it on top of like all the other
tensions that have been building up
about the trading and you know among
other charges that kind of like push the
whole thing into a skirmish and the
English were finally just kind of like
okay that's enough so in August of 1636
the English in the Massachusetts Bay
Colony they sent 90 soldiers to Block
Island and sent them to Pequot territory
to get revenge for the two traders that
they had murdered now they had like a
fight with the Menace's Indians they set
fire to their corn fields and their
villages and then they sailed on to the
Pequot territory and they tried to get
the picot out to come out and fight them
but they're gonna like [ __ ] you we're
not doing that either that'd they
weren't there or whatever but they
wouldn't come out and fight them so then
they did the same thing they're they
burn their villages and corn fields down
and then after that the Pequot decided
they were going to take revenge
so they actually attacked the fort at
the Saybrook settlement and this was
actually a very successful raid like we
were talking about before like Native
Americans battle tactics were actually
much better than the Europeans at this
point because they decisively won this
battle this was the longest engagement
of the war they pretty much set fire to
all the the Englishman's [ __ ] like all
their warehouses and whatnot and any
settlers that came running out they just
killed them so they you know they had
fought Europeans before so they knew
kind of the tactics they were familiar
with you know the the the ways
that they did battle and also like I
said they were a lot more familiar with
the terrain and their weapons were
better as we said now this war actually
ended up lasting 11 months and you know
involved several thousand combatants
there were several battles now in the
first six months it looked like the
Pequot were gonna win because they won
pretty much every battle that they
fought you know that it's not that the
English were complete dummies but like I
said the Pequot were familiar with their
fighting tactics and were more you know
we're more used to doing like guerrilla
warfare type stuff so they actually won
all of the battles in the first half of
the war yeah the white man's way a war
was war was something that happened kind
of like on a map yeah where you're
capturing cities or capturing you know I
think it was like something off of a gem
chessboard yeah that's not how Indians
did it maybe Indians were practical it
was more like Vietnam yeah it was it was
pretty much exactly like that but um so
like I said for the first half of the
world looked like the people are
probably gonna be victorious however the
turning point came when the Connecticut
colony declared war on the Pequot and
this was in May of 1637 and this was
after the Pequot had attacked an English
settlement at a place called
Wethersfield now this was actually this
pissed of the English awful lot because
apparently at this like women and
children were killed in this particular
siege the Pequod had killed them so the
English got really super mad about that
so so the English like gathered their
[ __ ] and what to fight the Pequod again
is like retaliation this ended up being
the most significant battle of the
entire war which is now known as the
mystic campaign or the mystic massacre
this happened for May 10th to the 26th
of 1637 this was 77 Connecticut soldiers
and 250 Native American allies who were
fighting with thee with the English they
attacked and burned the Pequot village
at mystic and killed 400 Pequod Indians
including a hundred and seventy-five
women and children killed them in less
than an hour
slaughter half of them were burned to
death so not a nice way to go yeah those
who tried to escape from you know tried
to run out from the fire and everything
like were shot by the English or were
shot by the bows and arrows of the
narragansett or the Mohegans who were
fighting with the English now people
might say oh man how could they do that
well different times man you couldn't
just make a peace treaty they come right
back and fight fight you later on this
this [ __ ] basically had if I was
basically had to wipe him out there was
only way to get rid of that well
thinking of the time yeah they pretty
much [ __ ]
oh my goodness which that's pretty much
the way it was going on back to Roman
times it wasn't really dividing dividing
the women and children from from the
Army is kind of a newer concept yeah and
it's also a European concept yeah
Indians did the same kind of thing when
they you know if they really wanted to
wipe out another tribe yeah they
probably you know their Indian allies
probably taught them how to deal with
them that might have been the case
because like I said the some of the
people like when the Pequot were running
out like some of them were killed by
other Native Americans like from other
tribes because like I said there was a
lot of resentment against the Pequot
because them and the Dutch settlers they
held like they were very powerful in
trade and like a lot of other tribes
felt like they were getting the short
end of the stick so there was a lot of
resentment there it didn't civilization
man this is Mad Max pretty much if you
had a if you wanted to go to war with
the tribe you better I'd better kill
them all yeah does it come back yeah
they did they did actually kill most of
the Pequot they took I believe it was
seven of them I believe that they took
prisoner yeah but that you know they
killed like several hundred people and
it was kind of like the defeat of the
entire tribe yeah
and they ended up like even like the
English soldiers and stuff and some of
their Native American allies they you
know the Pequot
you know after they started getting
their asses kicked they started like
fleeing like they tried to get away and
you know the the English soldiers like
went after them and they just you know
executed all the leaders and they just
like all the you know the men they
killed
the men they pretty much instant about
that yeah and they enslaved their
remaining children women yeah so that
was kind of like I mean that wasn't the
that was kind of the decisive battle
that the war went on for about another
you know month month and a half but that
was kind of like you know the big
turning point where whereas before the
Pequod had been winning but now you know
they were kind of like pretty much white
wiped out the last battle of the war was
called the swamp fight in Fairfield
Connecticut and so yes so that was a
that was the Pequot War and that was
just kind of like like I said I feel
like this is something that is not
really covered in history classes
well there's hundreds so much but yeah
there were so many but I mean this one
was kind of important too and it was
significant I guess because it happened
only a few years after the whole
Thanksgiving thing yeah where I think a
lot of people or they used to like used
to perceive oh there was this kind of
like so there was sort of like an uneasy
peace but but that's that's not the case
there evidently was a [ __ ] ton of wars
between Indian tribes that were never
recorded well yeah they probably went
because they wouldn't have written it
down or anything like that because of
this [ __ ] like that happened it was
happening all the time and but I'm
talking about during the time even in
the 1800s
time when the white man was there yeah
they were Indian wars going on in
certain areas that were just not
recorded yeah the white man Emily white
civilization didn't know didn't even
notice well yeah because they weren't
familiar weren't there yeah and they've
yet there was only before they got there
or they weren't really paying attention
there was all kind of stuff to happen
yeah so it's really interesting to think
like how much of that history has been
lost because a lot of it was not written
down yeah Attica Lee they didn't really
Indians for the most part weren't
writing anything down yeah they did
hervana tribes that had writing but I
think that was mostly on the East Coast
yeah and what they call there were the
Five Civilized tribes yeah because they
and part of the thing was is that they
had a written language those were all
agricultural Indians they weren't I
don't think they were they weren't
Buffalo chasing the Indians they weren't
like nomadic no yes well and that's the
thing it's like an it's sad because I
feel like a lot of [ __ ] that we know
like the common perception of Native
Americans like particularly their
history
is kind of as told through the eyes of
the European Rus they're the ones that
were at all they're the ones who wrote
it down for the most part you know we
don't really know what went on before
the Europeans got here which is kind of
like it's kind of sad all that low is
that it's like it's like thousands of
years and it's like we'll probably never
know went up and unless somebody invents
a [ __ ] time machine for the most part
of tribe didn't last too long a couple
generations so you're talking maybe 60
years some of them lasted over a hundred
years 200 years some of the really big
ones but they were constantly you know
merging with other tribes and breaking
apart and forming other tribes and then
later going to war with somebody else
and like I said ethnic group had a lot
to do with it too and there was more
than more than one Indian ethnic group
yeah there was several different
lifestyles going on different ways to
make a living like I said it wasn't just
one one just one thing type of thing it
was just like it was all different kinds
it was like a really diverse population
so you know I mean you're talking about
millions of people yeah
like before the play go like wiped a lot
oh man yeah so there's no tell I would
think that most of them were probably uh
oh man like as tax they weren't living
in cities most of them you know I mean
with a so I guess she said they weren't
like as tax you know somehow timaya
backs yeah kinda like I said although
some of them were like agricultural so
they did have like established
yeah like villages that lived and grew
food and stuff cuz like I said they knew
how to do that because they had to do it
because they didn't know they weren't
familiar with pumpkins and they knew
what ones they knew what was up and some
of them were fiercer than others and
evidently some of them were cool you
know just depended on each one they had
their own makeup yeah yeah so let's talk
about let's go back a few years and talk
about cannibalism cannibalism yeah
turkey day well you know I thought it
was kind of appropriate well it's just
like I was reading like all these
different things about colonial history
and I was just kind of like dark side of
colonial histories so like all this
different [ __ ] was coming up like all
the [ __ ] about the crime and
you know cannibalism and stuff like that
and I was like man I'm gonna put all
this [ __ ] in the show I don't I don't
care if it goes together or not so we're
actually going back to 1609 so this is
like actually this is prior to the
Plymouth Colony this is the Jamestown
Colony like kind of the first permanent
settlement so 1609 and for a long time
because that winter was so terrible and
there was like a lot of writings from
that time where people maybe suggested
that they had resorted to cannibalism
and various other things but they had
never found physical evidence of it
however now they have and I just read
this this actually I think they found it
in 2012 but I'm not sure like when this
article came out so they might have just
like reported on it fairly recently so
they did an excavation at the at this
Historic Site in Virginia in the
Jamestown near the where the Jamestown
Settlement was they ended up finding dog
carcasses cat carcasses horse carcasses
because that they were eating pretty
much every all their pets and horses and
whatnot you know because this was called
the starving time you know but they also
found some bones that they later found
out belonged to a fourteen-year-old
English girl who they had dismembered
and eaten damn like they could tell by
yeah she must have been dead though she
died yeah now the forensic
anthropologist that has that kind of led
this study he said I don't see any
evidence that the girl was murdered to
be eaten but probably she had just died
of something else they don't know what
but probably she had just died of
something else and then they just
decided to butcher her and eat her got
sick you know so he doesn't see any no
I'm not saying they didn't see he just
says he doesn't see any it's not in the
carrot not in the character that culture
yeah they I I feel like that might have
been a bridge too far yeah particularly
like a young girl like that was
somebody's daughter or love wand or
something they died yeah and they
decided well to survive we're gonna eat
her yeah it's probably just probably
sick I mean they they seemed like they
were really really desperate and like I
said I'll kind of get into that but it's
like so they found
these were Christian yeah and you can
tell this is what's really sad is that
you know according to this scuse me
according to this report by this
forensic anthropologist and this is the
same guy that worked on like the Jeffrey
Dahmer case the Kennewick Man case so
this is like not a slouch okay so he's
saying that the sad thing about this is
that some of the cuts that they found
like particularly the ones in the head
because it looks like what they did was
that they cut her head open they ate her
face and her brain like they would eat
the brain first because I guess it rots
the quickest you know what I mean so
they would have like cut open the back
of her head and taken her brain out to
eat and then they would have eaten like
made her legs in her face like you know
her cheeks and stuff but they're like
the cuts that are on the forehead are he
called them like tentative it's almost
like the person didn't want to do it or
wasn't very experienced in butchering
animals yeah and was like freaked out by
the whole situation he's like you could
tell that they were not they probably
did something kind of like skinned the
head and stuff make some sausage er it
seems like something like that somewhere
you really could because I wouldn't
think they'd eat a whole face they
probably cut it up a small pieces yeah I
imagine they probably would have made it
into a stew or something like just so
people wouldn't think about yeah what it
was that they were eating you don't want
it to look like it made something like
head cheese or something like I said
this isn't like the green inferno where
it's like they just like chopped the
dude up and like just ate the leg bit
they did to her something that he would
do to pork her you know I mean yeah
probably made some kind of head cheese
or sausage or something but he yeah he
said it looks like that somebody like
started chopping the forehead she's in
the winter and then yeah well because it
it was because the the winter had been
like so bad and they had been they had
eaten pretty much everything else that
even their dogs they'd eaten their
horses they'd eaten the cats they had
eaten they had started eating like rats
mice leather shoe leather
[ __ ] like that so they were starving so
this was kind of like like I said they
had they have long known and suspected
that there probably been some
cannibalism going on in Jamestown but
they hadn't found physic
evidence of it until just now so they
think what happened was that they said
they found these cut marks in her
forehead that were like really um like
someone that clearly didn't really want
to do it or wasn't that experienced it
says then it looks like they turned her
over and they said there were four
strikes on the back of the head one of
them looked like it had split the skull
open like I said they would split the
skull open and take the brain out and
they would have eaten that first they
don't know who this girl was they're
just calling her Jane like I said
they're not entirely certain if she was
murdered if she just died of natural
causes the forensic anthropologist
thinks she probably just died of natural
causes and then they just ended up
eating her I'll be the murder he's like
yeah he's like it just doesn't seem like
they would have done that
so it was available so they yeah that's
what I mean because what ended up
happening with these people was a
similar to what happened to you know the
later
separatists the the pilgrim and stuff
like that it's like what happened with
the Jamestown Colony you know this was
founded in 1607 and they actually had
104 settlers that had come over in three
ships but only 38 of them survived the
first nine months of Jamestown so like I
said it's just kind of like the pilgrim
situation where it's like they all come
over here but then immediately
starvation disease [ __ ] like that like
you know a lot of them are like
decimated at least you know the whole
thing like a bunch of them died they
think that maybe the water was poisoned
you know that maybe they pooped in it
like they were drinking it or maybe
there was arsenic in it or something
like that there might have been some
other diseases that they didn't know
about and when they got there in 16 a
you know in 1609 or in this couple of
years that region was going through like
one of the worst droughts like in
centuries so it's like they showed up
and like they're trying to you know eke
a living out of this [ __ ] wilderness
and you know the the atmospheric
conditions the you know the climatic
conditions are terrible most my
understanding of what mostly went wrong
with these colonies is that these people
they were basically suburban people yeah
that's exactly what you know and the
didn't have really any training and
they're kind of they're kind of mental
philosophy that they grew up with didn't
really wasn't real conducive for
somebody taking action what they would
do is they would get in the colony and a
big group and eat up all the supplies
and wait for somebody to do something
but nobody really did anything so they'd
all just kind of lean on one another and
the next thing you know they were all
starving
and as they died they just kind of eat
one another just they they they were
constantly they were the kind of people
that waiting to be told what what to do
I do kind of get that impression and
they were the kind of people that well
I'm gonna go out and go huntin I'm all
my wait for somebody else to go do it
her so it's something like that yeah I
mean they didn't really take matters
into their own hands I guess you could
say yeah think I think they were they
were a little too collective like two
collectivist yeah and I mean they would
wait for the system to feed them but the
system wasn't feeding them it didn't it
didn't know how to work in that world
well I think that I mean particularly if
you had been brought up at that time you
know in the 17th century if you had
grown up in England or in other in
another prosperous like place in Europe
you know they had big cities you know
yeah it wasn't like nowadays they didn't
have a lot of conveniences and stuff but
you would grown up in big cities there
was like a system in place there was
like a you know [ __ ] to do you know what
I mean for the system so you kind of
come to this wilderness I think it
didn't dawn on them that there was not
there was no one was going to there was
no system right that there was no system
it's like you had to like [ __ ] I'm
saying this based on my experience with
the infantry in the army
well we're [ __ ] you know walking
around building fortifications on top of
hilltops
you do what you're told and you wait for
the food to be delivered ya guarantee
you these guarantee these colonies were
kind of run kind of like a military
organization yeah it's where they he all
had their own little task to do and then
they're kind of waiting to be fed by the
collective and the guy who's in charge
of is some kind of preacher if he fails
then that means no one eats yeah and
because they're all doing their jobs
they don't say well [ __ ] the church yeah
I'm gonna go get a rabbit yeah you know
I mean instead they go no I'm gonna sit
here and you know dude they told me to
build this fence or I'm gonna you know
help dig this well or but it gets
desperate real quick so then they kind
of getting a defensive posture and they
just kind of wait around for supplies to
be delivered that's what I think was
going on maybe the boat will come maybe
that's what it was ships come yeah times
so it's like kind of like oh maybe we'll
come and then because the guys probably
gonna think that well if I go out and
catch a rabbit I won't be able to eat it
I just give it to them they have to
divide it up yeah so it's the same as
not eating yeah that's probably what
it's kind of like why should i expend
all that oh yeah so I'm just gonna sit
here away for the boat show up I think
they were all just sitting around
waiting for a book I don't never Ollie
what's going on I'm trying to think of
it inertia yeah I mean I can see how
that would happen inertia like I said it
kind of seems like nowadays it's people
that you know every now and then you
know we watch that [ __ ] [ __ ] what's
that show where they like draw people
out in the middle of [ __ ] wilderness
naked for exactly well it's kind of like
I would think that as many seasons as
that show has done you would think that
if you wanted to be on that show and
like campaign to be on the show and you
had to audition and stuff like that
it's like you think that you would watch
all of the other seasons and like be
prepared for the [ __ ] but it seems like
there's always one or two every season
that is not prepared it's like they drop
you you've naked and afraid' in the
middle of this [ __ ] wilderness and
you have to find your and fire you have
to find your water you have to run your
own food and it almost seems like every
now and then you get one person that's
on their dislikes surprised surprised
that it's hard it's like then it's hard
and it's like where's 7-eleven would say
you know none of them say that but I
feel like they're thinking it I think
they always get one or two of those just
to make it more entertaining for the
show I think there's also an effect
where well we can't we can't make it if
I go out and [ __ ] hunt a rabbit for
myself and everybody does it then that
means it's every man
for himself and the church is breaking
down yeah you know I'm talking about so
I think that's more they might have wins
you know we can't be every man for
himself
yeah I think that's really what they're
talking about but that's how the India's
did it could basically it was every man
for themselves go ahead go out go catch
some [ __ ] to eat yeah and meet us back
here when you got your stuff yeah that's
what I feel like they would kind of
share it out yeah sure you know cuz you
had old people and yeah but that weren't
haunting you know I mean but I don't
think they were doing that yeah well
like you said it was probably the thing
like they were so religious that they
couldn't think outside right and they
thought that well God won't let any
batches yeah and maybe that's what they
thought or maybe like if bad should
happen that was just like a test I think
was a mixture of very religious thinking
is you know they couldn't get out of the
box they were very a suburban but be
aware they didn't know that hidden you
have that word back then there was those
things a suburb but you know a modern
audience wouldn't know what support they
had a very suburban mentality I thought
yeah and they were also I think kind of
group oriented you know because this is
a church they're seeing themselves as a
church so to go out and try to make a
meet try to survive on your own because
the system is breaking down would be
kind of like a betrayal yeah I can see
that that's what they're doing that's
probably exactly what it was I would
have been like you know what I'm [ __ ]
starving and they're not fiag and you
just sit here on your asses it's Oh
holla at you I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
catch some fish okay I'm gonna go eat
all right I've got them Indians they
look well-fed yeah they probably got
some good [ __ ] they do I know what
they're doing okay they don't seem to
have this system you guys I'm gonna see
what system they have and I pretty much
think as we have with Roanoke the throne
I don't think there's much mystery about
that I think they were just kind of like
yeah this is better yeah we're gonna go
engine let's do this yeah we're gonna go
engine it's like it says is much better
we don't have to wear all these
restrictive clothing it's like we can
actually like we'll go hang out with
some dudes that know what's up yeah I
I think that's what happened with with
that it was in a way almost voluntary
starvation yeah they just didn't realize
it was voluntary yeah because they just
kept they couldn't think outside that
box like I said they're waiting for the
supply ship they're waiting for Amazon
Prime to bring them some food from they
sell themselves us an extension of
Europe and the end that somehow the
European system owed them a meal ticket
and that there's the supply ship will be
here yeah and as they did they did send
supply chef yeah but it's like well ship
didn't show up then you were [ __ ] yeah
but they didn't want to thank that well
yeah the Atlantic Ocean is very big yeah
and they're thinking well it's only a
month away that's only a few weeks and
it's probably already halfway here so
let's just sit here wait for two weeks
and they're gonna come bring us some
groceries yeah well like I said look how
excited they were they had a whole
Thanksgiving feast thing when a ship
that they shot was lost at sea turned up
and they were like yay party time and
then they had so they're super happy but
he could only hunt with those who stuff
they could only hunt with those
matchlocks
and I bet you all the powder got wet and
the match and they probably couldn't
wash it and then they couldn't hunt
without that they didn't know much about
trapping and then they probably didn't
know much a whole well you would think
they would know by fishing see that's
what I thought too but I feel like a lot
of this stuff I read said no to the
Native Americans kind of had to teach
them how to do that because then they
were [ __ ] I mean they have water they
were out in Europe right yeah and
they've been efficient they've been
fishing in their lakes for centuries you
would think that they would you know I
mean you would think that when you got
there is like hey it's an ocean there's
fish in there we can eat those word to
the wise you got all these dudes
prepping they're gonna prep for the end
of world and doomsday and they're gonna
store all this food you can store food
you can't store a lifetime of food you
got to eat on your own
yeah alright and the easiest ways get
you a fish hook and a line yeah just you
can catch fish all day long if you're
outside of if you're outside that's
definitely right it seems like the
easiest because it's like you don't have
to go running after animals hunt and I'm
nothing like that you just put out a
trap line drag a bunch of trot line with
a bunch of hooks on it yeah and it's
like you know fish is very good for you
yeah
and the very good part the food was out
there for the taking but you know maybe
the mentality was as well the waters
froze and it's frozen on top and it's
cold and I don't really want to leave
the camp I'm just late because I've been
in that position in Korea's [ __ ] cold
do anyone yeah I know it's like no one
wants to do anything in the wintertime
like that's you know starving and I know
this fish in that water the tops of it
frozen I'm gonna have to [ __ ] break
the top of that frozen water and get
down in there and [ __ ] put maybe I'll
just use my own fingers and you know
maybe I'll just maybe tomorrow the boat
will come yeah that's what they're doing
and they kept like procrastinate yeah
yeah so listen to this sad [ __ ] so like
several years later like one of the guys
who lived through it he was like the
president of Joe of Jamestown like
during it he wrote in 1625 he wrote
about what had happened and this is what
he wrote he said it was that close what
he said well this is what he said he
says having fed upon our horses and
other beasts as long as they lasted we
were glad to make shift with vermin as
dogs cats rats and mice as to eat boots
shoes or any other leather yeah yeah and
now famine beginning to look ghastly and
pale in every face that nothing was
spared to maintain life and to do those
things which seemed incredible as to dig
up dead corpses out of graves and to eat
them so they dead bodies also wonder how
long they had been rotting before they
froze well yeah I have high hope that
they were frozen yeah I mean you know he
also said and some have licked up the
blood which hath fallen from their weak
fellows so there's like cannibalism and
vampirism but not a mention of food
source of life what we tried to hunt or
we try to yeah it's like they didn't
tell you
I'm telling you I think I got it I think
I hey cuz you know they didn't even I
got it I got any material
I got a splice ed what did they think
was going to happen when they came over
here did they think that there was gonna
be like I said they think there was
gonna be like Amazon Prime they got they
got it where uber eats or something what
the [ __ ] it got cold they cut you cold
makes you lazy that laziness caused an
inertia
just staying put yeah instead of saying
[ __ ] it I'm gonna go get somebody
oh my guess I'm good it just kept
waiting because food is everywhere even
in the water like [ __ ] out even in
the winter
yes Lord but it's like you don't want to
starve to death wintertime they can set
up snares for rabbits there's all you do
is find trails that the rabbits are
taking there's a lot of [ __ ] but they're
not leaving the camp some reason to cool
lots and lots to cold to go like well
like I said they came from England which
is like a pretty which is like you know
it's it's cold and wet but it's not like
New England cold yeah you know what I
mean it's not like harsh winters like
that yeah they're winners are fairly
mild but they should have had you know
they should have had the clothing they
shouldn't it but like I said this is why
this is why I feel like they didn't
really plan ahead I don't think they
knew what to expect maybe they didn't
have the clothing I really don't think
they do what you respect when they do I
mean when I [ __ ] got a jacket
you would think yeah I mean you would
think that they had imagined it but I
don't think until they experienced it I
don't think you know what I mean because
it's kind of like one of those things
where it's like you imagine something
you don't know it's gonna be this that
and the other but when you actually
experience it it's kind of different so
I kind of feel like oh they they said oh
it's gonna be hard it's gonna suck in
everything but I thought did you know I
think they thought that they would they
would prevail like they would get it all
together yeah we know what we're doing
we're like who's city folk and you know
we're we're educated
yeah and stuff like that so I think they
knew what they would know what to do
when they got there and then when they
got there it was like completely
different we said some of these people
straight having [ __ ] to survive
[ __ ] Korean winters with a person the
506 infantry fifty degrees below zero
okay with limited sleep during team
spirit against the North Koreans all
your intelligence and all your education
can get thrown right out the [ __ ]
window in 50 degrees below zero hits you
yeah you think you're smart [ __ ] all
that well look it's just becoming a
zombie yeah and there's just
intelligence can out cannot out think
that cold yeah it's just mind-numbing
literally literally
so this become infantile and animalistic
quick yeah you just like I said there's
young brain can't function yeah that
some people crack but but most people
would crack yeah infantry guys
they've already been weeded out yeah
there's something you're worth shark
like we're already dumb it's like we
just like a shark like shark swimming
through the water I'm that that's my
shark swimming through yeah give a shark
lobotomy but it's still shark lebot
sharks with lobotomies does anybody eat
shark for Thanksgiving shark is
fantastic it is actually I have eaten
shark it's very good I like pretty much
anything that comes up short fish in
Marlin are a lot better though that's
true that's like the [ __ ] caribou of
[ __ ] fish you had caribou oh not
gonna know I don't think so fantastic
like better than any beef I've heard
that oh it's fantastic I would eat it
like I said there's very few things that
I won't eat yeah caribou [ __ ] like
some weird like you know how like it's a
weird [ __ ] like with oh let's bury these
eggs in the dirt for like a hundred
years and then William like when they're
rotting shows like I'm not gonna eat
that because what the [ __ ] man stop it
but it's I mean or like what is that is
it who does that the fins or something
like that where they like bury the fish
and it gets all rotten I don't know this
there's no Norwegians yeah but it's you
know anything like okay food rots and it
stinks and tastes bad that's nature
telling you do you just a protip I'm
just saying like other than that though
um I'll try pretty much anything I don't
like everything but it's funny because I
was a really picky eater when I was a
kid yeah but as I guess I didn't like
with sauerkraut couldn't stand even a
smell of it until I got to be about 19
20 and also and I loved it but I was a
kid I [ __ ] hated sour I can take it
or leave it I like it I mean cuz you've
made it before like we've made it
a couple of times I can eat it but it's
not my favorite I would rather not
sauerkraut on my butt with mustard
because oh it didn't you have that you
made um would you make like that pork in
the pot like sour cream sauerkraut yeah
yeah like a it's good but I would I
would just like rather have it without
you know I mean it's just one of those
things like pork sauerkraut mustard
potatoes most things I don't hate them I
would just rather not have Jeremy potato
salad mmm oh I do like German potatoes
yeah I wonder if anybody has that for
Thanksgiving but yeah so this girl that
they ate in Jamestown and she probably
wasn't the only one I mean like I said
because this was a bad winter and like I
said there have long been hints that
there were there was cannibalism going
on so I find it hard to believe that
there was just one girl that they ate it
was probably more than one but this is
just the one that they found like they
found her skull
they probably ate everybody to die so
they don't know who this girl was like I
said they imagine that they did like an
isotope analysis of her bones and stuff
and she had had like a high-protein diet
so they think that probably she was kind
of like maybe the daughter of somebody
kind of important they think that she
had come over you know like on one of
the resupply ships like in the 1600s oh
my god the cats are fighting yeah and
they think that more than one person
probably butchered her because they're
like you know what I mean where they ate
her brain and they ate like parts of her
face and stuff like that but the cuts up
there looked like someone that didn't
really want to do it or wasn't very
experienced whereas they also ate some
of her leg muscles and stuff like that
and the the butcher marks like on the
lower half of her body were a lot more
confident like someone that said so they
think it was at least two different
people that were butchering this girl
it's like like I said I'm pretty sure
that it happened like more than once so
like remember the dude that I was just
talking about that it wrote that letter
about them eating like their cats dogs
horses boots dead bodies and whatnot
this same guy
he also said because he was president of
the Jamestown Colony at the time right
like during the starving time in 1609 he
said and he I guess he wasn't
embarrassed about it because he admitted
this and
letter he said that he tortured and
burned to death a dude who said that he
had killed salted and ate his pregnant
wife now they have never found this
woman's body they found this girl's body
who was for about 14 years old so that's
why they're saying that there was
probably that cannibalism was probably a
lot more widespread like during that
particular time when you that dude he
tortured and killed and ate him no no
the president of the colony yeah because
this guy had admitted that he had killed
his pregnant wife put salt on her and
ate her
oh he ate his own know that he ate his
own wife so then the president tortured
burned him alive
as a punishment for assaulting that was
actually standard in the 1400s that is
the kind of [ __ ] you did this is sixteen
sixteen is still same time they put
people to the wheel and burning people
at the stake and [ __ ] like that yeah so
like I said this [ __ ] was going on and I
imagine that the more because they are
excavating in the area this was like I
said this fourteen-year-old girl's body
was the first physical evidence of human
cannibalism at Jamestown that they had
found but they are sure that they will
probably find more because like I said
there have been like other written
records that maybe that happen like I
said they were also eating dead people
eating corpses that [ __ ] like that so
now let's move on I got curious like I
said when I was reading about all these
kind of like dark side of colonial
history like I was all over the web like
reading all this stuff I was interested
to see who the first official murderer
was it separates it like in the American
colonies so lucky for me Google came up
with the solution
this dude was named John Billington and
he was a pilgrim that came over on the
Mayflower and also one of the dudes that
signed the Mayflower Compact as a matter
of fact he was actually considered
America's first murderer and he was the
first one that was executed for murder
it's at 1630 so now he was originally
from England born there about 1582 in
1603 he married a woman named Eleanor
Lockwood and they had two sons John and
Francis now in England they were very
poor and they didn't really
have a lot of prospects for their future
England was very overpopulated very
crowded and they didn't really have a
lot of skills I guess or whatever so
they decided you know in 1620 there had
been like these businessmen going around
who were jus like trying to recruit
people to go over to the new world to
colonize Northern Virginia so they
thought so this family thought well you
know we didn't really have anything
going on here kind of life kind of sucks
over here so we're gonna go to the new
world now problem was and we have
mentioned this a couple times in the
show before but because he took these
businessmen up on their offer he had to
sign a contract that basically put the
whole family into indentured servitude
for like seven years because these
businesses were paying for their passage
we're paying for them to come over and
like paying for them to set up you know
cuz they were looking for people to
colonize this area so they had to
basically go into like be labor for
these people until 1627 first so for
seven years so indentured servitude
caribou slavery yeah and they're
supposed to and they had to work six
days a week um you know they didn't
specify they're like whatever like
fishing you know carrying things from
place to place we you know supply ships
whatever it's like whatever
yeah whatever labor you had to do now
there was even at the time there was
like a lot of dissension about this
because a lot of people at the time were
like hey that's intention servitude and
we don't really like it even though like
I said these businessmen were
essentially paying their way but the
Billington's decided well you know it
sucks but we you know we're looking for
a better life so they get on the
Mayflower and they start coming over in
the new world now apparently even when
they were on the [ __ ] ship this
family started causing problems now they
were not Pilgrims and in the sense of
being like religious separatists they
were actually Catholics I believe so
they didn't really get along with the
separatists and the family didn't really
like this ever since too much of those
dude like Wendy yeah like when they got
on the Mayflower they found out that
like 40 50 of the people on the
Mayflower were these religious people
that were like going and they were like
oh man [ __ ] this so there was like some
you know tension there
um you know cuz they were you know
Church of England actually they weren't
Catholics they were a church in England
but yes so that kind of ended up
happening so while they're on the ship
apparently one of the sons I don't know
if he did it on purpose or accidentally
but Francis the son he fired a gun near
an uncovered barrel of gunpowder [ __ ]
and set fire to a cabin in the ship now
I've seen it reported that it was an
accident he didn't know what happened
I've also seen it reported that the
family were trying to like do a like a
mutiny type of thing so I don't know
which one is the true but but you know
they pretty much almost burned the
[ __ ] ship down like before I even got
here so they were causing trouble for
them guys usually the less glamorous
option is the truth that's kind of
whatever they got I feel like probably
it wasn't a mutiny maybe the kid was
just [ __ ] around the guys like I
wasn't really thinking about it back in
those days you know it was all like I
said matchlocks and black powder so
firing loading a weapon and getting the
match crime which is a damn morning it's
a burning rope filled with [ __ ]
gunpowder on the end of the serpentine
which is kind of like they didn't have a
hammer that is serpentine and then
firing it yeah all that whole process
made sparks yeah [ __ ] ton of them that's
what happen he may have not fired you
might have just lit the match which is
just the Rope burning you don't know
yeah but but yeah right by bathing in
barrel and gunpowder
maybe he did decide to just decide to
shoot it yeah maybe target practice like
I said these are pop guns I wasn't
joking yeah the boy on your average on
your average Matlock the pressure was
very low the barrels were very thin for
the most part and weak by today's
standards no some of them were thicker
but the muzzle velocity was very low so
chances are a lot of this [ __ ] was like
maybe 30 caliber 30 to 50 caliber ball
moving slow like for 500 feet of
you know for you ballistic guys you
don't know didn't sound like a gunshot
there's my boo real low pressure whoa
but it made a lot of sparks a lot of
burning embers
so really it's very sensible it would
sounds crazy why would you shoot a gun
next to the you note I mean the gun
really wasn't [ __ ] back then they
weren't very powerful yeah you know
that's why you had to have big caliber
with a big heavy ball because everything
moves so slowly this is before the
thanks - she was like yeah it moved
pretty see I'm just gonna move it was
kinda like you were just throwing it
real throw the bullet at you yeah you
were just throwing it real hard because
it was before smokeless powder you know
I mean it just couldn't propel a
projectile to high velocities it yeah
the gunshots didn't sound say made a lot
of smoke so young guy might think mom's
gonna shoot this [ __ ] it doesn't go
through anything you know what I mean
yeah so it's kinda understandable yeah I
kind of feel like the kid was probably
just [ __ ] around it was probably like
a little Hellion or whatever yeah it was
like old like maybe a teenager but now
later on flintlocks got better and they
make it they can carry a bigger they can
safely carry a bigger powder charge of
black powder so velocities did go up
over time you know yeah
firearms are around for a long time I
think you think they first appeared like
in the 12 hundreds real real real crude
was 13 hundreds at the animun but they
were they were the worst weapon on the
battlefield until then like the 1800s
yeah that's when they got good yeah yeah
but so you know whether or not it was an
accident or whether he was like trying
to blow the ship up but what does he he
didn't blow the ship up but he almost
did like he caused it like a huge fire
that's the Sun now as soon as they land
in Plymouth the settlement they
established the dad John Billington
starts causing trouble again
he basically lands he starts complaining
and kind of giving speeches about how
what they called discontented and
mutinous speeches so I guess he was
basically saying we're our own [ __ ]
we're not going to do
this labor thing that like even though
we signed the [ __ ] and said that we were
gonna come over and they were gonna pay
and we were gonna work for them just
like [ __ ] that we're not gonna do that
it's like we don't want to live in this
you know colony that's governed by these
like religious separatists cuz that's
not our deal so he was basically like
very vocal about saying like I don't
like this [ __ ] and getting into a lot of
trouble so you know what I mean so he
was like bitching and complaining about
that he did sign the mayflower compact
compact but he I don't know if he did it
reluctantly or whatever whatever but he
made it very clear that he was just not
about it and this was just not happening
so there were other people that were
kind of like in the same boat so there
were some kind of like I don't want to
say treasonous but they you know they
didn't want to go along with what the
colony was was doing so in March of 1620
Billington got in trouble again by
insulting Myles Standish who at the time
was the colony's military advisor who a
man that's a real man yeah he basically
like challenged his authority yeah which
I don't know what that means exactly
like maybe he just he was like he was
basically like you know yeah so at that
point they took him and he was sentenced
to public humiliation by having his neck
and feet tied together yes so now in
1623 I guess there was so much available
land that they had and the colonists
like divided it like everybody that was
there like got some now John Billington
only got three acres even though he was
you were supposed to get an acre for
every family member that you had now he
had a wife and two kids so he should
have got four but apparently one of his
sons John I think who was the older one
he was living with this other guy who
was named Richard Warren so he actually
only ended up getting three acres and he
was pissed off about that he also got
into trouble the year after that because
he supposedly was like secretly
supporting like other dissenters they
had been there was like a little group
of them who were like sending these
letters back to ink
and like trying to undermine like
members of the colony like I'm they were
doing like all this kind of like
underhanded kind of [ __ ] so um he was
like accused of being in with them but
they didn't really have any proof so he
kind of got away with it
now in in 1625 um Billington got into
some beef with this guy named Robert
Cushman nobody really knows what the
argument was about but apparently these
two like really [ __ ] hated each other
or like one guy burly you know he really
hated Cushman
William Bradford he was the governor he
wrote in a letter to Cushman he said
Billings this is what he said he said
Billington still rails against you and
threatens to arrest you I know not where
for so nobody knew why there was this
big beef between them he is a knave and
so will live and die for HP that's what
I mean knave that was probably a bad
thing that was like probably like
calling somebody like a [ __ ] ass clown
or something like that yeah so 1626 the
colonists took over the plantation
you know after they've kind of been
negotiating with the investors or
whatever so they divided the land in the
cattle like between everybody now John
Billington got the smallest allotment I
guess a lot of people maybe didn't like
him I don't really know why he got the
smallest allotments apisto about even
though he did get a house he got 63
acres he got like some of the shares
shares of the livestock cuz everybody
got that but for some reason he got like
the smallest even though he got I mean
63 acres that's a lot but he got less
than other people for whatever reason so
he was pissed off about that um he was
also pissed off because he wasn't like
super up in the social hierarchy because
he wasn't a member of the church so he
was a little bit of an outsider he
couldn't have pump he couldn't have a
run for like public office or anything
like that because him and governor
Bradford didn't get along so he was kind
of like frustrated by this whole
situation then it seemed like it kind of
came to his head when it came to a head
when his older son John
died when he was I think he was only 25
24 25 years old um nobody know I I don't
know if he died of natural causes if he
was murdered or something like that it's
not recorded there may have been an
illness because the guy that he was
living with also died right around the
same time so they think there was some
kind of disease or something so all of
these kind of like things his son dying
like his kind of like bad status like in
the colony and [ __ ] like that so it
seemed like it kind of like all bubble
bubbled up to the surface so around this
time John Billington gets into another
beef with another guy named John
Newcomen who was one of his neighbors
again no one knows what exactly the
dispute was about but apparently was
pretty rancorous so in 1630 apparently
Billington was out hunting and came up
came across John Newcomen like just
walking through the field or whatever
and decided I must shoot that
[ __ ] and he shot so yeah so
apparently he just [ __ ] he saw his
enemy I guess like a tit and he just
said yeah just gonna shoot him whenever
Eddie [ __ ] shot him yeah so yeah so
this guy he actually did get caught and
you know big and it was all in the
letters everything like that so he
actually did end up getting executed for
the murder and he is considered the
first murderer if the American colonies
you go John Billington guy that came
over on the [ __ ] Mayflower and I bet
you didn't I bet they never taught you
that in school yeah like some are coming
over on the Mayflower knocking
[ __ ] off and like I said he
caused some trouble before that's it
yeah now you know some people have said
that you know other people in the colony
really seem to like him and thought he
was a cool dude and everything like that
said so maybe some of them said well
maybe he had a reason for killing them
maybe that [ __ ] was an [ __ ]
you know you don't know so you're you're
only seeing things from like people that
didn't like him particularly but it did
seem like him and his family were kind
of like a lot of causing a lot of
trouble like even poor they came over so
he was actually hanged in September of
1630 the first official wild Tom
executed murder yet it was a while
time yeah but you know what it's always
a wild time now after he six years after
he was executed his wife Eleanor was
also found guilty of slander like
slander against a dude who was like a
church deacon yeah lying [ __ ]
and she got sentenced to sit in the
stocks she got whipped and she had to
pay a five-pound fine yeah and also his
surviving son Francis also got a couple
of small fines but nothing like Super
Bass so they were all kind of like a
little bit needless to say the the the
colonies were almost kind of like
totalitarian theocracies a lot really
but that's basically what they were they
you're not talking about American
democracy at this point Merrick America
is not not even a [ __ ] glimmer in
these people's eyes yet as we know it
really like I would say probably the
first American County characters were
guys like John Smith and Myles Standish
they were kind of American frontiersman
type guys yeah John Smith a lot to
remember him mm-hmm yeah he did a lot of
wild [ __ ]
yeah but the average person in these
colonies was like they were still back
in England yeah definitely they had that
same mentality it took a long time for
Americans during emerge well that was
another thing that I found in she cuz
when I was looking up [ __ ] about John
Billington the first murderer then I
kind of came across this other thing
because apparently and I didn't really
know this but apparently like criminal
records from the Plymouth Colony from
that time period are actually very well
recorded like they wrote [ __ ]
everything down and it all survived so
apparently after the there right before
the Civil War they all got published
like in this big like 12 12 volume thing
and they've been like republished a lot
of times since so I went through there
and like read like all these PDFs of
like all these [ __ ] crimes like this
tape and stuff like that it's like super
fascinating but it's like so apparently
there this is what I found interesting
about the crime and everything like that
because like I said it was still very
much based on English law when they came
over so 1636 the Plymouth Colony
actually like codified what constituted
you know a crime that they would put you
to death for and there were five of them
willful murder was first one the second
one was forming a solemn compact with
the devil by way of witchcraft so you
know willful burning of ships or houses
arson in other words sodomy rape and
buggery also adultery yeah although how
do you define library you know what
sodomy is we know what rape is what the
[ __ ] about the difference between
buggery and sodomy because by buggery
inside of me were the same thing I don't
maybe not maybe buggery is just like
some kind of weird molestation know I
always thought bugger he was like but
[ __ ] it I mean it must there must be
some more to this story yeah now
anything love more to these now I'm
gonna have to go to Google look at
buggery what is that means buggery
maybe that constituted like animal
[ __ ] - because you got in trouble for
that all buggering those animals maybe
that's what it was maybe that was like I
don't know yeah now even though adultery
was punishable by death at the time in
the Plymouth Colony they actually never
did execute anyone for adultery
however in Massachusetts Bay Colony in
1644 a woman named Mary Latham was
hanged for adultery for cheating on her
husband she William Latham who was also
on the Mayflower cheatin [ __ ] also in
Plymouth Colony in 1639 there was a
woman named Mrs Mary men name I guess is
how you pronounce it she was convicted
of quote-unquote uncleanness with an
Indian Oh
Henson but that was supposed to be they
didn't kill her though they just they
whipped her they like went through the
town streets and whipped her and then
she had to wear a badge just like in The
Scarlet Letter by Nathaniel Hawthorne
you guys she had to wear like a thing on
her clothes that said ad for adultery
uncleanness with India unclean the thing
is is it she's getting freaky with the
name yeah what was that exactly yeah
was she blowing him because you could
get married and most of those cars - in
India well it was something bad she did
something bad I saw it wherever they do
it they're normally out the middle
or that Christian I don't even care yes
some Christians who did accept she
must've she must've thought maybe she
would blow it baby somewhere out of the
woods oh that's it we gotta whip that
[ __ ] man you go Mary
what they did words are frequently well
yet they whipped her yeah they made her
wear like the adultery like you had to
have it on your cloth like on your
sleeve and they said that if she went
out without that badge on that they
would that they would brand it on my
forehead although they never did that
because I guess she I wonder how long
does she lasted I don't know
now that was also like in 1641 there was
an affair between a single guy whose
name was Thomas Bray and a married woman
whose name was Anne Linds furred and
they found out like the you know powers
that be found out about that
they both got a public whipping yeah and
they also had to wear the badge yeah you
know what I mean yeah
so I think like as the time went on
because like I said adultery technically
was punishable by death
they could execute when then one woman
did get executed in Massachusetts
however in Plymouth it seemed like after
a while maybe because it was so
widespread and it was like we can't kill
everybody like if we kill everybody for
adultery so I feel like the punishment
got a less severe so you would have to
wear the badge thing you would have to
be like publicly whipped and everything
like that be like look this is bad I'm
sorry you know we're just gonna do this
yeah so they had to do that yeah they
don't for one second think this has
anything to do with the American
constant Constitution if you guys are
aliens from another planet this is this
way this is way way before this way
before that
mr. religious this is this is like a
hundred years before yeah this is these
are religious colonies like I said this
is this is a religious law yeah they
were a trip they were a [ __ ] real
trip
yeah they had all kind of interesting
ideas yeah I had to mention this one B
just because this name is so phony so in
1662 there's this guy named Thomas Byrd
he got double whippings because
apparently he committed and this was the
quote several adulterers practices in it
and attempts so I guess he was like try
so he got punished for like doing it and
for trying to do it
on succeed I guess man wanna take
apology for thinking about that's what
probably they did what the spiritual
evidence yeah I see the ghost and she's
flying around she's tormenting me oh my
one of this booty you're guilty that's
what I mean well the best thing about
this is that the woman that he was
[ __ ] around with it he was attempting
to [ __ ] around with yeah her name was
Hannah bump ass yeah which I was like
did they make that up I gotta see that
for myself
she also got sentenced to whipping for
yielding to him this is the quote for
yielding to him and not making such
resistance against him as she ought okay
that's good that's victim blaming harder
that's like so she had a sunny review
must have wanted it yeah you wanted to
see that's right but then it's hurt but
pretending to resist yeah she didn't
fight him harder harder and I guess he
like got the booty and then yeah so she
got blamed for it - she got whipped
however it was kind of like a wash
because I guess Thomas Byrd also had to
pay her ten pounds for the quote was
satisfaction for the wrong he hath done
her satisfaction ten pounds for the
school that was a lot of money back then
yeah so I mentioned the first person
executed for murder who was John
Billington there was also these three
guys
their names were arthur peach Thomas
Jackson Richard stings and there was a
fourth guy named Daniel cross now this
is interesting because these guys were
actually convicted of murdering an
Indian whose name was and I hope I'm
pronouncing this right but his name was
Penna one man Chris oh good this was in
1638 and they like set upon him and
we're going to rob him but then they got
caught
now Daniel cross got away like Union
yeah okay they did but the other three
were convicted to death by Hank so they
all got hangs like other than the guy
that got away so I thought that was
interesting because plymouth was
essentially saying killing a Native
American that's like killing an English
person like they didn't distinguish
which I thought was kind of interesting
what that matches up with everything
that I've heard about that period
everything that like this whole [ __ ]
cartoonish idea that white will show up
just start an Indian genocide it's not
it should happen yeah it's like even the
religious colonies recognized Indians as
God's children yeah now I don't know
what the deal was about the dirtiness
with the Indian I don't know it wasn't
clean unclean this yeah what is that
about I don't think it was unclean it
was she was doing something something
into it English she wasn't married -
yeah that's what that would I could see
how they were about adultery it had yes
something like that
but it wasn't normal sex yeah must been
like it was they hadn't thought of so
there was no there's like what is this
that's going yes so some kind of like
must be bad is something I thought of
was she was she giving him a [ __ ] you
know or was she blowing him you know see
I would've thought I mean hand jobs and
[ __ ] you would think that that has
gone back to the beginning of civil
times it was something bigger than
English prostate
or they hadn't thought of a punishment
for it wasn't someone something like
that it was something that wasn't really
sex but had a dirtiness to it maybe
maybe um Teddy [ __ ] the dude maybe
she gave him a Cleveland steamer I don't
know what is it I never heard that one
google it actually don't google it maybe
she was Teddy [ __ ] dude it was
something that was you saying maybe
maybe it was awesome that was
technically not I think I think it was
poop I think it was maybe cuz you know
how people are into poop it's a
Cleveland steamer he's like taking a
dump on their chest oh that's what I
mean well some people I doubt that I
doubt even I'm not i but I doubt they
could think of that
no man there was but there you see
people in every golden shower okay maybe
that's what yeah I can see how they
would think that was like it's like
you're peeing on the dog yeah maybe
that's dirtiness yeah yeah it was baby
yeah baby it was some golden shower a
get some water sports watch they were
engaging in better yes I don't know it
was something like that no but yes so
yeah so the fact that they actually
executed three guys for attempting to
rob and killing an a Native American I
thought that was kind of interesting
employment there was also in 1648 this
is [ __ ] up this woman named Alice
Bishop was hanged for slashing the neck
of her four-year-old daughter Martha
with a knife Walmart that was sleeping
yeah she murdered her four year okay so
[ __ ] like that's been goin is like these
aren't Puritans these are like pilgrims
but everybody's like oh these little
pilgrims they come over there little
buckle shoes and their little hats and
everything it's a Thanksgiving and they
were doing this kind of serial killer
[ __ ] yeah she might functioned no [ __ ]
holy crap again went crazy I guess huh
so there were actually like I said they
never convicted anyone of arson because
apparently that wasn't a problem cuz
like I said you could be put to death
for burning someone's house or their
ship or whatever cuz that [ __ ] wasn't
cool but as as far as I know they never
convicted anybody of that however there
were two Witchcraft Trials in Plymouth
Colony and this was way before the Salem
Witchcraft Trials these were in you know
those were in 1692 this was way before
that however both of the Plymouth Colony
Witchcraft Trials ended in not guilty
verdicts and the people that were
accusers were actually got fined for
making false accusations so this was
like before that whole [ __ ] had taken
hold where'd the whole spiritual
evidence and everything so there was a
whole new so like she's a witch and
they're like nah you got a page just
stop it so yeah now here's this is
interesting too in 1637 I found this
John Alexander and Thomas Roberts were
charged with and convicted of lewd
behavior and unclean carriage one with
another so yeah there was some buggery
you
there was a sexuality go there you by
often spending their seed one upon
another or spending the scene which was
proved by witness and their own
infection so they saw them spending the
seed one upon the other yeah dan yeah
so someone caught them there yeah
someone caught the gay men this they
were yeah and they got a trouble and I
love this - it's like the said Alexander
found to have been formerly notoriously
guilty that way yeah I guess he was no
because he was a gay guy back in the day
that was a Sox ban that was the original
American Oscar Wilde I guess so
and he's like and seeking to allure
others thereunto so trying to like
recruit other people into the game so he
didn't get executed though he actually
got a whipping and then he got burned on
the shoulder with like a hot iron and
then they kicked him out of the colony
but they didn't execute him though um
the other guy got sentenced to a
whipping but he didn't get banished but
he wasn't ever allowed to own any land
ever again um they said they said unless
he manifest better desert which I don't
know what that means
I don't know unless he just like stops
having but sex with other do manifests
better desert with pride means unless he
turns his [ __ ] around that's yeah I'm
just like desert like I don't understand
like where that like an technologies
like came from in 1642 a 16 year old boy
Thomas Granger who was a servant of the
Mayflower passenger love Brewster was
caught and later admitted to be steel
axe with various of Brewster's livestock
damn and he was executed and the animals
were executed - will they enjoy it I saw
the look on that yeah it was into it
they used to do that they used to like
execute like the [ __ ] animal yeah
they thought that was the 'nobody
certain it was in the vibes in Leviticus
yes an abomination so yeah that's
[ __ ] too [ __ ] up in 1660 Thomas
Atkins was tried for incest with his
daughter Mary
the jury found him not guilty of incest
which was a capital crime also but
sentenced him to whipping for incestuous
attempts toward his daughter so I guess
he didn't do it he was going he was just
going after her yes she I guess she
fought him off and ever well he I guess
because and also he'd do it but didn't
want to execute they didn't want to
execute him and I think that there were
mitigating circumstances because they
did mention that he was like intoxicated
with drink quote/unquote so maybe they
said well he only gets incestuous when
he's drunk so maybe yes like let it
slide oh [ __ ] it now it was a weird
situation back in those days usually
they all got in the same bed they did
yeah like they just had a little bitty
housing yeah a little bitty houses they
set the same bed made sometimes put
boards in between the brothers and the
sisters so they would know genitalia
could be mashing yeah there's a weird it
was a weird culture that it's a weird
culture a weird time that is a nothing
as weird as that is these are
one-bedroom dwelling there's this idea
of some kind of prudery going on not at
all
these are one-bedroom well yeah you had
to [ __ ] in front of your old family and
they were all secure than fronting each
other yeah it's just that like I say you
didn't have a choice they grew up
watching each other screw each other
yes there was no expectation of privacy
yeah weird it is very weird to think
about now yes but I guess it's weird to
think that like I guess most of human
civilization has been laced like that
right like the you know the registration
that we have now about having privacy is
like that's a fairly recent invention
yeah we're retro actively you know what
I mean going backwards in time and
trying to place modern sensibility on
them yeah they weren't like us no not at
all well yeah in a mini private aspects
they weren't like us yeah because he
just weren't raised like that yeah you
just I mean you know you just got used
to like a totally different imagines or
imagine growing up seeing your parents
have sex yeah all the time
no we're here and it would just be like
a thing like you wouldn't even yeah you
wouldn't know any different huh
cuz everyone would have the same
experience there's like yep that's what
happened yeah and then there was like
you and like for your siblings all
same [ __ ] bed yeah [ __ ] like okay now
this this I thought was really
interesting they're saying like you know
you kind of feel like I feel like a lot
of people have a perception of like
anti-smoking laws and that that's like a
very recent invention but no they had
that [ __ ] back then - they were prudish
about it in 1637 Plymouth Colony enacted
the first anti smoking law see what good
that did
you got a 12 pence fine they ban smoking
that is you got a 12 pence fine for
smoking in a street barn outhouse or
highway and for smoking anywhere further
than one mile from your house needless
to say banning smoking didn't work no it
didn't no and then if you got caught a
second time then the fine increase to
two shillings [ __ ] man back in the
[ __ ] I think it was in the 1300 that
banned crossbows see how good that is it
was a weapon of mass destruction
[Laughter]
wielding it would make you damn
dangerous for the battlefield alright
anyway so we've probably gone on long
enough
about Thanksgiving and I hope that all
of you guys who are in the United States
anyway if you celebrate Thanksgiving I
hope you have a good one yeah you know
and for those of you or not eat all the
food those of you who are not in the
United States understand that
Thanksgiving is a universal phenomenon
well anybody in other countries you can
eat your ass off no matter where the
[ __ ] you live and if even if you're in
like you know I'm in the alien lands of
Europe you can Kyle that's like on
another planet all right the the you can
rest assured that some of some of your
people were over here doing all this yet
yeah they're calling the food and yeah
at all yeah one day you two can be
American and eat all the food try and be
as fat as we are if you try harder we're
seriously it's like I said it's just
gonna be me and him and the cats
probably so much [ __ ] food we're just
gonna and we were just discussing
because you know we have to go to the
store again we already went like on our
trip but we forgot a couple things we
have to get whipped cream for the pies
we have to get you
bean casserole because he just decided
he about that yeah and I'm gonna make
some that cream corn I'm gonna make so
so he decided he's gonna make the
Brazilian cream yes to like ask his mom
like for the recipe though cuz yeah you
don't know if I that's all on you get
just Brazilian style cream corn it is
really good it's just whole kernel corn
with condensed milk based cream in it
yeah it's not like American creamed corn
where you take corn and then you like
whip it up yeah yeah the thought the
kernels are whole and it's in a cream
sauce yeah it's good yeah really we had
it last year it's kind of sweet a little
bit a little bit of sweet with some corn
flavor in it
it's RIT fits with Thanksgiving real
well that's my Brazilian influence on
Thanksgiving yeah and you can find that
recipe online
like I said Jean cream you guys tell me
like what your weird like Thanksgiving
is like I said my Thanksgiving like I'm
a very firm a very like traditional like
you know family like England Irish stuff
like that so we always did like the very
even had like the pickle tray with all
the relish on it and [ __ ] like that like
that everybody has with all the
different pickles like for whatever you
and we just very traditional we didn't
have anything weird but it seems like a
lot of like other parts of the country
like especially like in the Midwest
where there's like a lot of people like
Norwegian and stuff like that like they
seem to have a lot of different stuff so
now I'm like kind of interested because
I'm you know I'm really into like food
history we still need to do a show I'm
going to show you another Mississippi
thing you make a cornbread stuffing
yeah okay the dressing or stuffing but
it's all by the same thing it's got the
onion it's got all the same [ __ ] you
normal onion celery sage and all that
onions and celery but you add a whole
bunch like a whole handful of finely
chopped dill pickles into it and it's
good I'm down I love pickles she's had
it it's good isn't it yeah it's good I
love that you can't really tell a huge
difference there's pickles I put pickles
on my salad just it just adds kind of
like a seasoning to it yeah it's a good
weird although I think a lot of people
do it I think they do too I think that's
pretty common
like I said it's like a lot of the [ __ ]
that I grew up with I didn't know how
common it was but then like I said I was
reading the Wikipedia page where they
were talking about different regional
variations and I was like pretty much
what we had at Thanksgiving dinner was
like super this
yeah it's like even the kind of stuffing
that we made you know like I said we had
the pickle tray we had like the kinds of
pies that we had like all that kind of
[ __ ]
very very very tradition have anything
we are just you talking about that no
pop tomorrow mind what doing [ __ ]
sweet tasty
okay well this is just too much if
there's only two of us man I can't eat
all this hey we'll just see we'll just
look at the sweet potatoes and getting
the list right yeah all right but yeah
so just a couple basically like I said
we're kind of we're both on diets so
it's like we've been like starving for
like several days and I'm soup I'm just
starving up to that now Thanksgiving Day
I feel like that song only that's the
only day of the year
when you're just allowed that's the
whole point of Thanksgiving yeah at
least in the United States it nowadays
is you just eat as much as you can
possibly watch him st and you watch the
mst3k turkey day marathon which they now
stream on youtube and then you sleep and
then you sleep and then you have a nap
and then you go and eat some orange
juice you I mean you leave all the
spread out we do this every year because
you start early yeah you know I mean you
you have to start at like noon or 1:00 I
mean you have to put the turkey and like
really early in the morning obviously
it'll like cook it but we're making a
bunch of stuff ahead of time so like you
know by about 2 o'clock you go in there
and you get a big [ __ ] plate full
maybe two plates full or three if it's
you I can eat a lot I'll sit there and
watch MST and stuff like that and then
you'll be like man carb crashed yeah and
then you take a nap and then after a
couple hours you wake up from your nap
and then you're like man I'm gonna go
make a sandwich I'm gonna go get another
plate it's a foot of a go get some pie
it is it's a food coma I'm in it like
it's so good and yet it will my stomach
will hurt and I almost feel ill and
nauseous but in a way it's kind of worth
it you know but then it almost better
than that is like the next day and then
you can have like a sandwich like with
the turkey yeah and dressing and mani
you could do whatever you want for the
next two weeks out of there you just
make stuff oh I know I'm looking
everybody's doing the same thing at
their house if they're pretty much if
they're American it's weird because it
feels like I feel like Thanksgiving is
something that I mean most people
celebrate in some way or another and it
seems very it's it's one of it because
Christmas is kind of all over the place
like some people do this so I get better
than Christmas now um yeah who says
presents but yeah I don't know I look
well Thanksgiving like I said I like how
simple it is yeah it's just it's mostly
just about foods about you eat yourself
into something and everyone else is
doing the same thing so you know you
don't have any responsibilities that day
because like pretty people like almost
everyone is off work except for all the
poor people that have to work getting
ready for like [ __ ] Black Friday and
all that [ __ ] happened yeah but uh so
that sucks but it's like I know no one's
gonna bother me for work it's like cuz
everyone's going to see their family or
whatever and you can just like lay
around and eat and Brazilian people it's
it's it's kind of like Carnaval
yeah like the American version the
carnival except it's about food yeah
Brazilian Carnival is about booty
Thanksgiving is not so much a
celebration of booty yeah girls on
floats with booty yeah that should also
be the title of something girls on
floats with booty yeah somebody needs to
write a poem called that man when I was
in Brazil during one of those [ __ ]
carnivals it got so [ __ ] bad even
then even though from the news crews
covering carnival were drunk is it they
just they just started videotaping each
other it's like it's like one of those
dams Star Trek episode if it goes Star
Trek episode where they said you know I
mean the civilization collapses for like
it goes on for like four or five days or
some [ __ ] like that station collapses
you came and buy anything because
they're just drunk or hungover or
they're looking at booty
and dancing and Inter it's it's wow
that's cool though because I feel like
makes Mardi Gras look like nothing well
I feel like everybody every culture
needs that I mean especially one because
I feel like in the u.s. particularly
we're very like 15 yeah because it's
like we're very like tightly wound it's
like you know we worked too hard as no
vacation time and [ __ ] like that so I
feel like that's something that a lot of
cultures should bottle fall and present
everyone's that time of the year went up
most of the AIDS is transmitted but yeah
I mean like you said there's there's
something very nice about I mean I love
Christmas
I mean Halloween's my favorite obviously
but I mean I love Christmas I like all
the iconography around it and everything
like that
um but there's something really nice
about Thanksgiving like I said it's just
a very simple I mean a lot of people
watching football and show that I'll do
that like I you know I watch em estate
but um but you know it's just it's
basically just based around food and
like hanging out with your family and
[ __ ] like that you don't to go anyplace
you don't did let me got a cook but you
know you just like Leia and eat you can
eat as much as you want and no one will
judge no would be like me get your fat
ass so like no one will do that it's on
one day of the year and that's pretty
[ __ ] awesome
some people have egg nog yeah that's
another thing you're gonna have to add
Italy you have some egg nog left in
there got some in there
yeah and you have the one that already
has alcohol in it so you don't got ramen
at all I'll cook something you have to
add the rum separate yeah it's already
in there yeah yeah alright so again I
hope you guys enjoyed this rambling
Thanksgiving special and if you were
celebrating Thanksgiving please have a
good one out there and be safe and
everything like that like I said if you
like the show like share subscribe blah
blah go to our patreon page if you'd
like to support the show or a good War
blog 13 o'clock podcast WordPress comm
and there's a button in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you'd like to give a
one-time donation it would be much
appreciated this has been episode 171 we
will see you next time
Happy Thanksgiving bye
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]